[Music]
welcome everybody
to the
leftovers the wait is over
let's run
me
welcoming to the h3 family and our three
million dollar set we spared no expense
hassan biker
thank you thank you for thank you for
having me
thank you i'm ready to
okay
we plugged you two go ahead show us his
socials again i'm ready to uh oh look at
that yeah hell yeah
i'm ready to i'm ready to bring the
patriotic voice to this that's what this
godless channel thank you hey come on
that's that's what i'm here for
that's right
real american voices will be heard
finally what is the leftovers listen
i've had enough of you guys complaining
that i you don't want me to talk about
politics so i went made a whole [ __ ]
show about it
but
the spirit of this show
is not serious policy debate
it is bringing righteous justice to
these [ __ ] bags
that's it okay just clowning on idiots i
love that yeah i'm i'm a fan i mean
that's what i do
regularly so
when you hit me up i mean when we did
that original
uh podcast your podcast yeah like this
is
is this a thing like are we
are we vibing right now right and you
know and then after that we we uh
we covered the gamba stuff and i was
like
okay we're yeah that was vibing yeah
we're vibing pretty hard well i'm a fan
i always watch your i don't i don't
catch the streams i think you're
psychotic by the way you stream like
every f every day every day you take the
weekend off or something bro like i took
today off kind of seems a little it's a
little capitalistic if you ask me yeah
working hard seven days a week working
eight
eight days a week oh [ __ ] yeah that's
right i put an extra day in there
cranked it up to 11. that's right i mean
i'm i'm doing like eight hours every day
minimum and that's like lower now but
that's mostly because like i just i have
nothing going on yeah i feel that you
know what i mean i just i
it's what i love doing
well god bless dude they say if you work
it if you love what you do you work a
day you don't work a day
something like that
because
it doesn't it doesn't feel like real
work you know what i mean it's just
i i mean you know you i was just for fun
too yeah i mean dumb idiots on the
internet on a regular basis there was a
point when i was doing like the weekly
videos where it was turned into such a
[ __ ] grind but since we were able to
pivot pivot to doing the podcast with
all these
guys and everyone here that i love
uh it does feel like a joy and a
pleasure and this to me i want to say i
think there's some people are going to
be freaked out by this format they're
going to say i hate politics
too much testosterone
whatever yeah i'm sure leave your
complaints
too much testosterone i think some
people will say that right beca there's
a lot of people that i think were
you know like the female male dynamic
that i had with trisha oh true
but i just i could not
i mean i ra i i don't know for me and
everyone here we were thinking like
we just kept thinking
hassan [ __ ]
well i'm moving the turk
yeah
can you forgive me i actually we thought
for a second and then we quickly
corrected ourselves but we were like jew
and arab and we're like turks aren't
arabs so yeah
that'll frustrate the turks i didn't say
i was just i almost but i did the
research and we came back strong well
i'm i'm muslim so
you know right you got that
but turkey didn't say muslim i said arab
no i know i'm saying well you're jewish
now you're assuming now you [ __ ] up
wait why because not all arabs are
muslim hassan no i know but i'm okay
okay i'm muslim so all right
there's that at least kind of i mean i'm
the worst muslim yeah i'm the worst jew
so we have that
yeah yeah i'm totally so we have that we
have a lot in common we do
um
i'm going to let you people see people
thirst trap over me
yeah people strap over you
i they don't really but
not anymore not since the barbs came
after me
the what the barbs the barbs are you
unfamiliar with what the barbs are no
what is that the every stan
culture
group on the internet has like their own
little name
nicki minaj's fans call themselves the
barbs oh the oh the bar oh yeah of
course i followed your beef with the i
didn't know there was a bar why the
barbs they just called themselves the
bar i think barbie maybe i don't know
bart oh my god i'm so sorry please don't
dox me
please i'm so sorry
well you know
for those who don't know what hassan's
talking about he got into a public spat
with mickey mouse mickey oh it's all
because she's a mouse he said mickey
mickey minaj because she's a [ __ ]
disney mouse oh no it's over got him
we're we're literally cancelled all
right trust me i've been canceled by
k-pop stands literally nothing could
ever hold a candle to that i'm gonna be
honest with you i feel like barbs are
barbs they're vicious so have we found
the trinidad trinidad swollen bald
gentleman yet and we located him no the
health minister looked all around and
they just they couldn't find them
pull up that clip dad let's start there
so anyway what what i want to say oh i
need to thank our sponsors hang on okay
thank you to hellofresh quip policy
genius and stamps.com capitalism baby
that's four sponsors come on i'm pulling
you to the dark side i i know i'm i'm so
like what do we got to do i don't know
are we going to do reeds
okay all right that's going to be
it's going to be a weird i always feel
weird when i do like avery's because
it's like a muscle you know what i mean
yeah i mean i've been doing it so long
it's like yeah
i sold my just like use once you sell
out and then you're like [ __ ] like
slip and slide that money highway yeah i
mean you can't get a a
three million dollar secret bunker like
the one we're in currently i mean this
studio is insane
yeah good good intentions don't pave the
way for yeah exactly
but anyway what i want to say
is that to people who are skeptical of
this concept just give it a chance
because we are here for the laughs the
goofs this is entertainment front and
center every time give this episode a
shot and tell me you don't love it
because the stuff we're talking about
here it's all reaction it's all comedy
it's all high octane [ __ ] energy dash
with a little bit of alpha brain which
how did you um alpha brain pump course
yeah i i got yeah i mainlined it right
before i go so that's it let's talk
about the nicki minaj thing real quick
because it's fantastic
nick show that pull up the tweet first
of all that that caused the whole oh
no he's fine
it's nicki minaj's cousin's friend's
testicles who are swollen from taking
the facts that's the claim hmm
but it's not anything to do with the
physical effect of the vaccine that
makes our political class mad it's the
last part of nicki minaj's tweet that
enrages them the part where she says you
should pray on it make the decision can
you pause
like bro how are you going to breeze by
the fact that he just goes her cousin's
friend's testicle got swollen it's in
the chiron like they put it in the lower
third at a certain point
one of the most popular yeah one of the
most popular news broadcasts in the
country if not the most popular i think
he's like going back and forth with greg
gutfeld or something i don't know how he
got famous but
it literally had like the lower third
like nicki minaj's puzzles swollen
testicles or something which is wild
like this is
it's a clown show yeah but like tucker
who is traditionally does wouldn't
would wouldn't give a [ __ ] about nicki
minaj i mean she would be a subject of
ridicule easily
you know corrupting the youth oh
speaking of the speaker of the witch
yeah nicki minaj's cousins testicles
became swollen headline baby
that's right it's like it's such a wild
thing to like have a serious news
broadcast and it's like breaking news
nicki minaj's cousin's swollen testicles
number one rated news show yeah
it's like the the wild i mean it's wild
he will propagandize everything
obviously
but to be fair to tucker i looked
and you know i i let my i sicked my
community on this too on this little
project
maybe he might be a [ __ ] barb dude he
might be a nicki minaj stan because i
think he's a barb the only time i've
ever seen tucker cross like he brought
up nicki minaj one time in passing in
the past couple of years where
he basically was saying like america
isn't
america's in a state of decline because
like you know
young girls are uh
lip-syncing the nicki minaj or something
but other than that he is like
obliterated
uh everywhere
pop like all that stuff and you know
cardi versus nikki like
he might be he might be a bit of a barb
i don't know
i just i i like to think that you know
he's just getting down with nicki
minaj's music well so um like bring back
that the the headline again i want to
re-examine that where it said the
cousins testes got swollen
because let's be honest this is
journalism
um
cousins testicles no
[ __ ] get it straight tucker you're a
journalist cousins friends testicles be
swollen you hack
get the facts straight and this is why
this show's necessary and i hope you
guys understand we're here to correct
the news with real news
go ahead play it
does he show that the tweet in that
segment no i would love to see that
i would love to see what that scrolling
test oh by the way and the story is
just hoping the tweet because i got to
tell you the whole story is that her
cousin's friend's testicle became so
swollen after the vaccination
that here i've got it that he it ruined
his wedding his [ __ ] wife dropped his
ass because he's got the big ass nut
which is so unappealing to her she
canceled the whole wedding but if you
have normal testicles like i was willing
to marry you but now i love gigantic
ones i can't do it his nuts was his best
yeah it was his best property perfectly
symmetrical normal sized balls was what
he was like high and tight yeah
my cousin in trinidad won't get the
vaccine because his friend got it and
became impotent okay so so he can't
breathe his testicles became swollen oh
my goodness his friend was weeks away
from getting married now the girl's
calling off the wedding after his nuts
have become engorged
so just pray on it and make sure you're
comfortable with your decision not
bullied exactly
there you have it guys it can't be
anything else it's it's probably that
it's the vaccine i think yeah i think
everyone was like he definitely got a
std yeah that and cheated on her yeah if
it happened at all i mean who [ __ ] i
mean but the fact that tuck the dick
carlson actually picked this story up is
why we do the show
yeah
it's just
i don't know why they never go with like
a normal thing is that like anti-vaxxers
are never like
yeah you know my my friend got
kind of sick after the vaccine right
it's always like and was rendered
incompete or was incapacitated from the
medicaid sticking to my body yeah it's
like i've turned into magneto it's the i
can manipulate this prove [ __ ] like or
cool stuff like i can manipulate metals
now yeah to me that sounded great yeah i
was like i'm magnetic i've always loved
magneto and yeah the aspects of being in
makes me want to get double vaccinated
yeah
should we finish that video i kind of
want to see his righteous indignation
about the giant balls if we could please
yeah so the studio is real by the way
that's why it was taking so long yeah
uh three million down
yeah huge space
it's yeah we were gonna we're gonna do
it in my house first
but i was like you know we should use a
smaller place than my house which is the
largest yeah right sits on the largest
plot of land in los angeles as many of
you know
yeah i heard you got a house
just [ __ ] up i know rages them the
part where she says you should prey on
it make the decision that's what angered
people like a free human being that's
what angered people talk
so our media and public health officials
didn't like this because they make their
livings bullying people so they couldn't
let it stand
this [ __ ] actually thought
people were mad about the prey and think
about it i mean the giants won't testify
he knows he knows that that's not what
they're mad about he's just that's why
he glanced over the the comical cousins
friends testicles part and immediately
switch it over to here you have a free
thinker they don't want you to be a free
thinker they don't want you praying
you're almost turning into like a like a
religious freedom thing it's always it's
always ridiculous yeah so uh in short
they wasted so much of the poor trinidad
the government's time
if you can roll that
some secretary came out and was like
we've
investigated the giant testicle claim
they looked all over this man they
looked long and hard we could not find
the testing we had check marks we we had
uh we had uh
what do you call that [ __ ]
will you stop people on the road oh
checkpoints we had checkpoints we were
examining men's testicles
couldn't find it
devastating dan can find it right dan i
can pull it up give me a second i'll
find it so yes so claims are being made
one of the reasons we could not respond
yesterday in real time to ms minaj
is that we had to check
and make sure
that what she was claiming was either
true or false
we did we
unfortunately we wasted so much time
yesterday
it is
as far as we know at this point in time
there has been no such reported either
side effect or adverse event
and what was sad about this
is that
it wasted our time yesterday
i mean trying to track down because we
take all these clicks and you can pause
you know i pre on one hand i feel like i
could have saved him the time and be
like it's not true bro yeah i don't know
i don't know what happened there i don't
know why they were like all hands on
things we gotta find alerts
so what so what if the barb has been
doing to you have they really been
[ __ ] with you oh i mean not anymore
it was like for the day of like i
ratioed her once yeah and then as soon
as that happened it was like over
because like that's what stan culture
revolves around like everything's about
like you fell off plus ratio whatever
um so the moment i ratio her it was over
oh here we have another white
supremacist like oh you became a white
supremacy
the most the most racist person in
america was was myself for
for literally saying
the person that you're hyping up nicki
minaj is a white nationalist
which by the way
yeah yeah and and and that she had
reduced that to a simple party
disagreement like i was just like
whatever you know
they just don't want they don't want you
to to agree with uh those on the other
side it's like yeah but the some of the
people on the other side are white
supremacists and white nationalists
i mean there's racist people on the
democratic party too but like
god damn like this dude literally makes
a living
trafficking
racial agitation
talking points propaganda talking points
well you'll see we have at the bottom of
our show the hog of the day
is going to be tucked with some of the
most racist [ __ ] oh yeah straight up
like kkk talking points yeah once he was
done once he was done defending nicki
minaj's cousin's friend's testicles he
was like
back to calling haitian migrants like
dirty and all right you know we need to
purge them we need to whip them on
horseback yeah good optics
um did you know that you sent me an
email in 2016. i do you did know that i
do i've talked about this on my stream
before i won't even remember for some
reason
i forgot i was just searching for your
email address
bro there's one more i think i sent you
an email even before this you go what up
we had never talked before you dropped
like what up i i had sent you an email
even before that way back in the day too
when i was at young turks yeah
i i used to be uh did you usually greet
people with what up i mean i was just
like very unprofessional
clearly
clearly i think you responded though
didn't you yeah i think i responded yeah
yeah i i think i i don't remember where
it worked
i think i was like yeah i can do it
you're like oh it doesn't work it
doesn't fit in our schedule so
peace out i was this was 2016 i was a
lower rung employee in the tyt franchise
so when i yeah
sending what up emails no i um back then
i was like i i was just trying to do as
much like
work as i could but my real title as you
can see in that email is business
development manager that's lofty which
was
um
which was like you know doing all the
advertisement operations and sales
strategy stuff like that and then i was
i was just actually trying to be a
producer and host i mean you got there
i did
i did i did get there i am i am doing
that now
but you'll never be this you'll never be
this i oh yeah so don jr
gonna be a frequent topic on the show of
course the one of the most embarrassing
human beings
uh ever
and something to bear in mind as we
watch this is the uncanny resemblance to
this character
from men in black he does he feels like
he's
crept into someone else's skin
and
he looks like what like heart pressure
looks like like right right he
constantly looks like he's like
like he's squeezing so hard
all the time and i don't know if that's
like a coke thing yeah like an adderall
thing allegedly of course uh in
minecraft yeah i don't know if uh you
know donald trump
well there's a reason he's on cameo bro
the guy needs some money daddy's not
giving him allowance
i don't even know if donald is doing
well money-wise to be honest with you
well he just did a triller thing i don't
know if you followed that oh yeah for 9
11. in trailer for 9 11. he was honoring
9 11. i saw an interview with ryan
cavanaugh the guy who put it on
piece of [ __ ] by the way he was a cute
he's bro brian kavanagh falsified a
document and lied under oath and say bro
it's a whole thing but yeah ryan
cavanaugh's piece of [ __ ] but anyway he
he said about paying the trumps he's
like how much was he getting the trumps
on he goes not as much as you would
think
damn
you get you got called out by ryan
kavanagh who apparently is a villain
here oh yeah i don't know anything about
him [ __ ] horrible dude yeah i just i
saw like his name seemed familiar but i
mean if he's the trailer ceo
won't be doing any fights on there
anytime soon
here's dawn um
oh this is great this is gonna be huge i
think well guys saturdays are no longer
just for the boys they're also for the
newest and greatest
sporting tradition in probably the last
50 years and that is obviously the f joe
biden chant so if you're in a college
football game
first of all you're a whole ass adult
bro like you can't be like i'm 30
right i just turned 30 and even i feel
like saturdays are for the boys bro like
like what are you are you trying to [ __ ]
freshman at college campuses like what
the [ __ ] is this like this guy likes
them younger than keemstar yeah off
i don't know if that's possible
right legally yeah legally it's
definitely definitely not even
keemstar's in there in the legal
category but
um
it's just so uncomfortable like and he's
trying somewhere to be his dad it's like
this man he he is the human embodiment
of insecurity and being unloved as a
human he is so whack dude he's so
[ __ ] whack it's like so wait till you
hear his pitch it makes me uncomfortable
just watching him like he's just so
wormy i don't know how to describe it
well yeah do you you know this character
for men in black right
yeah the one that there's like a there's
like an alien inside of his body
sugar yeah that's him
he's about as uncomfortable in his skin
as this guy yeah oh yeah
if you're at some sort of other sporting
event and they get it going make sure
you record it send it my way
post it up here tag me and we can let
the rest of america know exactly how
america feels about joe biden so
video it tag me i'm going to do my best
to repost them because again there's not
a lot of times where you get a new and a
great sporting tradition but the f joe
biden is certainly up there it's
certainly one of the best uh i think
it's got legs i think it's gonna go for
a long time
and that's always
yeah no this has got a lot of likes the
greatest tradition ever everybody's just
screaming [ __ ] joe biden dude first of
all i mean like i i'm not even the
biggest fan of joe biden okay like but
that's besides the point it's like
like
this is
like who is going to be like oh man i
love
this [ __ ] fake dude
he's going to be like oh yeah dude i
love donald trump jr bro i can't wait to
go to my favorite sporting event and be
like f joe baden
and then they're going to send it to him
has he posted any yet uh dan i think
there was one uh
i did see one tweet and now i'm piecing
this together i saw like
like maybe 10 people at like some
[ __ ] college football game doing it
and i guess now i know who's responsible
for it the legendary the new american
past yeah this is a video this is a very
new tradition because that was from his
instagram story today like it's it's
still up as far as i know oh so maybe
he's taking credit for it then maybe he
saw the video and now he's like this is
what we're gonna do believe me it's
gonna be great it's so
he's so like
it's so pathetic like you are
you are basically telling everyone that
you will never have sex if you go to
college
okay and you you watch like joe biden's
[ __ ] instagram videos like oh my god
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're doing
but like you go to college you watch joe
biden or joe biden what am i saying don
jr uh don jr's instagram videos and then
you try to start this chant
and it goes viral it's over no one will
[ __ ] you ever
again you know oh we have an example
here what do you got for me
was it ohio state or something oh here
we go so this is don junior's handiwork
guys changing the world new american
pastime
wow
this is incredible
that is from a couple weeks ago so i
think it sounds right he's just trying
to take credit what a [ __ ] culture
vulture dude he's just like
he's straight vulturing this this
grassroots movement have you ever seen
the grassroots movement of [ __ ] joe
every
yo so hold on
you say you'll never get laid
well i have evidence that you're right
have you heard
of
conservative [ __ ] uh
republican hype house on tick tock yes
so this is basically evidence that uh my
favorite brawl you guys are [ __ ] if
actually i'm so glad you never talked
about it because it's so fresh no i was
i was if if you hadn't asked me to come
on i was this is what i was going to do
so glad this was my next content avenue
so there's a twitter account and and i
swear i would think this was parody i
still
am
not a hundred percent it's not parody
it's 100 serious so it's called the
republican hype house and i this is
going to be a concert this is going to
be a weekly for us
so here's one of a dude getting mad
about a doctor um
uh you know
debunking masturbation myth so and
oh here you go
nope nope
nope so in that video this gentleman
debunked several supposedly common myths
can you turn it up a little bit
bro we get it you love america dawg what
the [ __ ] the only girl i want to [ __ ]
is a statue of liberty
she's french though so oh [ __ ] it
that's just community types of
masturbation now it's unclear whether
he's talking about masturbation in
general or masturbating to pornography
bro he's talking about masturbating it
doesn't matter what you [ __ ] are
watching he's talking about does
masturbating shriek your penis dude okay
here's here's my actual criticism like
if i were to do one of these like
[ __ ] tick tock videos i don't know
how to
i'm 30 i don't know how to use this
stuff because i'm not keem i'm i'm not
i'm holding it i'm not trolling on
[ __ ] tick tock okay looking for my
next girlfriend i'm right um that i'm
not doing yeah
but
if i knew how to do one of these
stitches i would be like yo if you're a
doctor why are you debunking
masturbation
that's i know that's not the point no i
i think it's fair there's a lot there's
a lot dude there's a lot of dudes
there's like a whole community of dudes
no fap you know about that dude i love
they go if you don't jerk off for a year
you get suit you could see through walls
they're all canadian there was a
canadian uh ppc party member who's
running for a seat who was literally a
semen retention specialist oh he's
especially it's a feeling now he he
yeah he would do like breathing into
your balls like he would do like those
holistic like breathing exercises yeah
he would breathe into his balls i mean
he got [ __ ] owned like he did not win
which is i don't know i don't know i
mean the retention would give him yeah
that edge i i don't think i think
canadians are just not ready for the
truth
i think we both have bad habits of
pausing too much okay oh yeah so we have
to unite against our tendencies let's
just watch this goon uh talk get angry
about mastery i just love that he's
going to be super serious
he's going to seriously debunk the
doctor yes so in that video this
gentleman debunked several students
common myths about the negative effects
of masturbation now it's unclear whether
he's talking about masturbation in
general or masturbating to pornography
but in this video i'm gonna lay out you
several reasons why masturbating to
pornography is harmful you should stop
doing it and that those advocating for
its use are harmful actors all sources
are cited speed round let's do this
number one it lowers motivation and
focus and it makes you depressed number
two it lowers testosterone number three
it causes sexual dysfunction even in
young men yeah
this guy is i'm sorry to posit what the
doctor literally just debunked this
yeah so this is what is known as a gish
gallop for those of you who are you know
also sexless uh like myself
uh that is what is a common debate lord
tactic what he's doing is like throwing
a bunch of papers at you uh supposedly
he's like giving you the empirical
evidence it's like it's just the title
oh [ __ ] peer-reviewed oh we don't
know anything about these uh like are
they peer-reviewed are they debunked
with like ivermectin and [ __ ] too all
the goddamn time and
like this is just ridiculous does anyone
think that math first of all
masturbating is is let's be honest many
of us the only thing we have
yeah it's all we [ __ ] have are you
really gonna tell me it's make me
depressed it ma it got me through high
school i know me i wouldn't have
survived without that [ __ ] i wouldn't be
here today without masturbation well
honestly like
i feel like this dude
this dude lays one rope one time he's no
longer a conservative
you know what i mean he's so pent up
he's so frustrated because he's just not
jerking off just crank one out dude yeah
i mean seriously that's what dude these
really conservative religious people who
like
the mormons and uh other sects of
whatever the [ __ ] you know the jesus
show don't even give me something and
they go through an adhd jump off point
again if you if you okay let's just
let's focus but yeah they don't let even
jerk off it's like bro how you gonna you
your
organization you're not knocking off too
much that's why you can't focus me too
yeah exactly i got to retain more semen
bro she's right dude i can't even get
through okay i gotta retain more semen
focus
[Laughter]
number four it's so addictive that it
can give you stronger cravings
get you addicted to drugs that's a
self-report dude bro i jerked off one
time and i smoked crack the next day
yeah no he he's just like you know
you're yeah
yeah i jerked off and and now i'm
homeless because like i'm addicted to
masturbation like
sometimes i think about
you know this is a tangent but it's
something i think about homeless people
obviously masturbate
oh
dude but like yes and you know how
there's that one
there is okay there's this one dude
he is a furious masturbator in public
and i don't know what to do about it
like because you know whip it out and
[ __ ] he's supposed to be he's in a
vulnerable situation right like right i
would feel super vulnerable with my dick
out in public right this dude
i always catch him like cranking one out
and he's just doing it in the [ __ ]
he's taking back the power yeah dude and
he's just like staring at me and i'm i'm
i was driving down and i i i stopped for
a second i was like what the [ __ ] oh
this dude is cranking one out it's so
and it doesn't stop they like they're
like it just seems like i don't know man
it's just it's wild to jerk off in those
conditions but you have to do it yeah i
don't know if that's like classes of me
or something well the sad part about it
is that
um the unfortunate sad part about it
obviously is that like they should have
permanent shelter so yeah jerk off in
their own yeah you know listen if i
could give the guy a shower
where he could jerk off he's gonna jerk
off in your shower actually he probably
is like nah [ __ ] that i like jerking off
i'll go outside once you once you do it
outside it's over it's like it's
liberating all right let's hear more i
got to focus on this guy he's so serious
about masturbating come on brain damage
and a decrease right now
number six it causes memory loss and
memory
loss
where am i
yeah
that's true it jerked off where am i
disorder and number seven it fries your
dopamine receptors there's a very famous
quote by aristotle i count him braver he
who overcomes his desires than he who
overcomes his enemies yeah aristotle was
a big fat guy he he was talking about
masturbating he was famous
didn't every single person in that era
just like [ __ ] boys and [ __ ] like what
are you talking about exactly he was
never fat because he was just like
always yeah he was just [ __ ] always
[ __ ] [ __ ] left and right
yeah boy [ __ ] oh god that's disgusting
you've never heard [ __ ] before i guess
not in the context of a boy i mean no
boy puts his
it's just
it's what
it's what yeah
community calls uh oh that's anal sex oh
they that's like the sanctioned word
bussy [ __ ] is like a meme oh okay you
haven't seen the memes about like
putting lucy behind everything
let give me another example cussy car
[ __ ]
like from the cinematic universe of cars
and is that [ __ ] in a car or [ __ ]
a car no no that's the cars from the
cars pixar cinema oh cinematic universe
where you can [ __ ] them no they [ __ ] one
another because like there's car babies
and there's like male cars you know i
didn't think about that yeah
don't worry
this is where i'm here we have the
anatomy of the of the cussy that's a
real that's that's right now why would
the inside be like so
like he's made of metal i just don't the
autonomy of this doesn't make sense
that's that this is important stuff that
we're looking into now
we're never i wonder if this is what he
was talking about no this is what
happens
and then this is like get off the screen
where am i i jerked off yesterday oh no
pornography does not have your best
interests in mind be a strong and
disciplined human being do not be a
slave to follow me
channel the energy into lifting weights
or reading a book strengthen your body
and mind
dude what's up like he's got the
american flag back there like what are
you over compensating for dude like
what's going on i feel like there's
nothing more american than beating off
yeah i know it's so dumb you know who
doesn't want you to beat off dude
communist china that's right
yeah you're on tick-tock no i'm just
making it up i'm just you never know
what the chinese though he's on
tick-tock
i could see china outlawing masturbating
you never know those guys are wild um
probably [ __ ] you know improved
productivity or something he's just
exactly
no longer nofap so here's another from
the uh republican hype house
he's the same guy eh
no no they all look the same all right
and they have the exact same [ __ ]
background with the american flag
oh no it is the same guy never mind so
many rhinos so this guy's actually
calling okay so obviously
what's her name
for sure i can't even see but he he's
calling
ronald reagan a rhino
well ronald reagan did give amnesty to
undocumented immigrants so he he is
how can you be a rhino if you're right
if you're ronald reagan he's like the
father of modern these zoomers don't
respect conservatives they don't respect
the og's it's like how
so rhino is republican and name only
right yeah
no ronald reagan is the the archetype
like is the reason why america is so
[ __ ]
it's like it's like being like fake
christians and then showing a picture of
jesus yeah
well jesus was kind of he's a fake he
was kind of a fake ass christian like
yeah that kind of he literally did not
deny uh healthcare coverage to those
with leprosy i already would say that
fake is [ __ ] fake
uh there's one more by them oh this
one's good wrap your head around this
one dude
i don't know if you can dude this is
like checkmate atheist um
it's always the same
i can't tell is this the same guy or a
new guy
this a new guy
i can't they all look the same but i got
like
like i don't know if i have like face
blindness or something people make fun
of me all the time for it i just like i
literally think they all look the same
per like the same person do you think
that about all white people
yeah i think i might be racist again do
you think that do you have the same
problem with turkish people
no interesting there you go
yeah
i don't know
some of these some of these dudes they
just look exactly i don't even take talk
they're all born in the cornfields and
yeah well this guy so the funny thing
about this is this is known as uh
bisexual lighting okay so he has he has
lighting yeah so he's got the rgbs
popping off like
a is shirtless uh obviously you know
obviously cares about the way he looks
that's kind of sus
i'm just saying
you know that's a really good point um
yeah so here uh try to wrap your your
mind around this logic wired dem
suddenly posting about the new abortion
ban
but we're silent about 13 lies lives
lost overseas
but that's not even related like what
are you
sure maybe because they don't care about
life
wait but that's consistent
why are dem suddenly posting about
consistent that's like literally in in
the in the [ __ ] up logical universe
that he tried to craft yeah like
democrats don't care about a
contradiction yeah we are straight up
evil yeah but his abortion is murder as
everyone knows yeah dude how the [ __ ]
how are you gonna be like 30 000 likes
by the way but like that's kind of weak
though that's not great i mean it's not
that bad for this kind of logic i'm just
saying like how are you gonna be like
you know trying to do that [ __ ] like
um i'm a sexy zoomer [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then be like
abortion is baby murder like you're such
a [ __ ] nerd dude or doing like sexy
thirst trap and then being yeah like
actually masturbation causes you to have
amnesia
[Laughter]
it's so weird like who wait i want this
guy again this is the masturbation dude
yeah
he's
yeah he's becoming my favorite already
yeah god plus says his shirt whatever
that is
all these repub christians all for
banning abortion because it's murder
didn't yell's bible say life starts at
first breath not heartbeat ooh slick
always claim that being pro-life is
purely a religious stance yet they're
always the first ones to bring up the
bible during an argument now i've
legitimately checkmate hit this wait so
he's jackman he's saying like [ __ ] the
bible no he's saying
girl it doesn't make any sense what do
you say wait i want to hear the rest of
this i want to hear we've never seen
anyone who's pro-life cite the bible
during a debate and i've been in this
political thing for a long time now yeah
we know we'll simply
he's like wait hold up he's like i've
been doing this politics thing for a
long time what do you mean bro you're
just like taking 17. you're posting on
take part and you're literally 17 years
old dude like what the [ __ ] yeah dude
i've been i've been up into the trenches
dude advocating for you know i've been
outside of planned parenthood like you
know telling all the girls i've bombed
five planned parenthoods by now yeah
well don't tell me what this is about
yeah i was in the january six rides i
was 15 years old
i impaled an officer at on january 6th
what the [ __ ] is this human beings is
wrong on the contrary pro boards are
real quick to bring up out of context
bible verses and random what's out of
context
yeah what the [ __ ] omnipotent
omnipresent but all of a sudden mr tick
tock guy is like
that's out of context i thought the
bible didn't matter by the way yeah
nothing better than seeing people who
hate jesus and you know support killing
babies attempting to quote the bible
these killings are ridiculously demented
i love how people who are pro-abortion
god this is like so this is the whackers
debate because it's like
it's like 75 of the country agrees and
has historically agreed including like
supreme court justice from the
federalist society uh that agree that
roe v wade should
remain the lord and that might change
because you know they're demons over
there in the in the supreme court but
um this is like
a total non-issue that they have that
evangelicals have like
latched on to for so many years now it's
incredible that the abortion issue
after all like when when was um
when was it did it become like a federal
ban i mean how long ago was that it's
been like decades yeah and and like fr
for now after all these decades and all
the social progress we've been through
the fact that
we can come so far
across the spectrum on so many issues
and still
somehow abortion
rights are being
once again it's like on the verge of
becoming illegal straight up again yeah
the supreme court is gonna take it on
soon um
i don't know what will happen though
because like like i said even brett
kavanaugh uh used the term super
precedent
um when describing roe v wade right
which is like that just means that it's
like well established and i mean hard to
you know shake off well i'm not i'm not
gonna be mad about i've already made
fifty thousand dollars reporting people
who got abortions in texas like i'm
crushing it so yeah you're caking up
yeah that's right
i'm i'm starting uh me and dr bounty
hunter oh bro it's i mean like i'm i'm
killing it we're gonna we're gonna get
dressed up and you know put on night
vision goggles and be looking for like
14 year old you know girls outside of
planned parenthood 10k keemstar is
getting involved for other reasons but
i don't know he was just like he heard
you know we're looking for girls in
texas he was like vulnerable young girls
yeah
um we've got the cucks coming up next
but it's our ad break you should get
excited for okay i'm excited massage
first or second ever yeah the one on my
podcast uh
like
this week for the first time i think i
didn't even see it i wasn't even seeing
the cut how'd it feel i mean will
carried it like my co-host he carried it
for the most part i was kind of ripping
on it a lot that's okay i think that
much i think they might have cut it oh
they just removed it they might have cut
my part out because like i don't have
like full edit control editorial control
over it because we're working with
another company
[ __ ] yeah so i don't know
all right we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break and we get back get
ready to get cucked
i'm so ready what you can say on twitch
what you right no no you can say
whatever oh you can that was that was
some silly goose [ __ ] you know they were
just being silly silly billies okay well
i'm gonna get cucked
you're we're all getting caught we're
getting cooked all right
hello fresh what is hello fresh hassan
psych
i knew you i knew you were gonna say i'm
i'm putting on the smile i don't know
what's going on i'm the experienced
capitalist let me take the lead on okay
you you you take the lead on this one
yeah
well let me i'll educate you hello fresh
they send you
pre-measured ingredients
fresh beautiful so you can make
mouth-watering seasonal recipes that are
delivered right to your door and
ice is iced out bro fresh cold liquid
nitrogen boom boxed up
skip the store to the growth skip the
trip to the grocery store and count on
hello fresh to make comb cooking easy
fun and affordable that's why it's
america's number one meal kit take for
example this uh
sam and ian cook this up what is this
cream of corn or what is it what do we
got here this is green pepper and corn
chowder damn dude what tell me was that
is it bomb as it looked it was so bomb
it was amazing i wanna i want more we
have leftovers luckily
and how easy and fun was it to make this
it was very easy were you guys giggling
the whole time
with cackling with ghee glee
yes
fantastic we love that
fall is busy by hella fresh recipes save
you time you'd otherwise spend meal
planning shopping and shopping so you
can get back what matters and hello
fresh family-friendly menu is a big win
for back-to-school season with easy
delicious recipes for drama-free dinners
what do you think about that hassan i
you know when i'm always thinking about
dinners i'm like i really just i don't
want a side of drama
no drama with this meal i would like to
have a drama-free meal
let me go that's perfect because hello
fresh that's what these crazy i was just
thinking it's amazing go to
hellofresh.com
leftovers14 to use the code leftovers14
for up to 14 free meals including free
shipping wait the give you 14 free meals
[ __ ] are just feeding america
this okay there's wild yeah
i mean they're stepping up where the uh
conservatives have left
that the car service said no child left
behind and hella fresh said holding my
free meals
14 of them to be exact that's insane
uh
so guys
uh go to hellofresh.com
leftovers14 and use the code leftover14
for up to 14 free meals including free
shipping free shipping there's our
number there's a reason why they're
america's number one meal kit thank you
thank you
quip you know i love quip it is the
greatest
toothbrush technology this world
and the next world even and heaven
itself
has not even matched this toothbrush
technology
what is quip it's a perfect little
toothbrush the softest bristles in the
game you ever use a toothbrush the
bristles are too firm it [ __ ] all your
gums up
always
i'm always i'm always using toothbrush
that's making my gums messed up you you
go for the extra soft bristle i i i mean
until now i've had the
the you know what is the one that has
like charcoal in it oh you go for the
charcoal brush i go for the charcoal
brush and it [ __ ] your gums up i feel
like it does yeah yeah you got to get
the extra soft but the good thing about
quip is that they have these special
kind of rubber bristles works great to
clean your teeth but it's so soft i feel
like it's not it never damages my gums
you could brush your heart's content the
other thing about quip you turn it on
it's an electric toothbrush and it times
out so you get that perfect dent i know
what this is yeah it's like it
vibrates to tell you when you're done
there was a reason why i was on oprah's
oh list and not because it's a shape of
a vibrating sex uh
are you allowed to say that i don't know
i've said it before oh okay but it just
makes me laugh that it's called on her
oh list and it's like a little vibrator
that's not how i use it i brush my teeth
with it but multi-purpose
vibrates every 30 seconds to tell you
you're done with that quadrant 30
seconds 30 seconds 30 seconds get you
that two-minute dentist guaranteed brush
every time it's the best uh best
bristles in the game as well but yeah
conservatives are constantly complaining
about mask wearing
and then when you ask them why they're
like well what about you know your
breath stinks and then you know the mask
is capturing that if they had quit yeah
maybe you're not brushing your teeth
good enough exactly dude you're worried
about your own stinky breath do
something about that i'm doing ad reads
dude i'm we're breezing through this
baby yeah the quip smart brush for
adults and kids connects to bluetooth
track when you track when and how well
you brush get tips and coaching to
improve your habits earn points for
daily don't laugh
hey
this is a [ __ ] bluetooth toothbrush
you ever [ __ ] wrap it up
i'm just thinking like you know
just like you're on your iphone you're
like watching your child brush their
teeth you're like
jonathan you didn't it's not a camera by
the way no i know it's not like a
colonoscopy no it doesn't need i don't
think they they would put a camera in
yeah that's not priceless effective
jonathan i know you didn't do quadrant
two okay you stopped we got to work on
quadrant two now a little yeah you gotta
step your [ __ ] up
yeah that's good parenting i don't care
what you say earn points for daily good
brushing bonus points can be used uh to
complete challenges and you can redeem
rewards for products gift cards and
discounts you got a problem with that no
i like that thank you
um in addition
in addition you're gonna get brush heads
you just take off the brushing you pop
it on boom you're done you're also gonna
get floss toothpaste mouthwash gum
refills every three months for five
dollars shipping is free and you can
save money and skip the hustle and
bustle of in-store shopping five million
people are using quip okay god damn
numbers don't lie
start getting rewards for brushing your
teeth today go to get quipped dot com
slash leftovers right now to save ten
dollars on equip electric toothbrush
that's ten dollars off a smart electric
toothbrush at get quipped dot com slash
leftovers that's g-e-t q-u-i-p if your
dumb ass needed me to spell it for you
they're making me spell it
get quipped.com leftovers quip the good
habits company
summer is coming to an end and the
leaves are about to fall and while
mother nature does her thing prepare for
the new seasons you can all do yours by
taking a dump mother nature it sounds
like someone's taking a dump they're
like it does sound like that but that's
not what they're talking about but
that's not what they're talking about no
not at all
they're talking about life insurance
right
let me tell you about
policy genius policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over dozens
of top insurers all in one place why
should you compare because you'd be
saving 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policies you could
also be saving 1300 or more per year on
life insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies
the license expert at the policy
engineer worked for you not the
insurance company so you could trust
them to help you navigate every step of
the shopping and by process that kind of
services are policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google itself the most trusted company
i'm one of those guys i'm always writing
reviews on engineering providers
what why would you lie like that
that's right is is illegal a lie on the
internet why would you go on the
internet and lie like when i'm backed
into a corner i find myself right like
tucker carlson yeah
and eligible applicants can get covered
in as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning scene winning policy
option that swaps the standard medical
exam requirement for a simple phone call
we love that this exclusive policy was
recently rated number one by forbes
advisors higher than options from ladder
ethos and bestow where the [ __ ] those
are [ __ ] though yo [ __ ] those guys dude
you bet what's up dude it's bestow
bestow yeah how about get a [ __ ] name
that my dumbass can pronounce losers
yeah
their fault not mine
getting started is easy head to policy
genius.com uh how much life insurance
you need and compare personalized quotes
to find your best price when you're
ready to apply the policy genius team
will handle the paperwork and scheduling
for free policy genius doesn't add on
extra fees head to policygenius.com to
get started right now policy genius when
it comes to insurance it's nice to get
it right
it's definitely not nice to get it wrong
if you got a small business you know
there's nothing more valuable than your
time so stop wasting it on trips to the
post office and start saving time at
stamps.com
stamps.com makes it easy to mail ship
right from your computer save time and
money with stamps.com send letters and
packages for less
with discounted rates from usps ups and
more since 1998
stamps.com has been an indispensable
tool for one nearly one million
businesses
i love the postal service
yeah but you know what you what's better
avoiding the trip the house go don't
stand online samsung speak the service
of the us poster then ups shipping right
to your computer whether you're an
office setting invoices or a side hassle
hustle etsy shop or full blown warehouse
shipping out orders stamps.com will make
your life easier
all you need is your computer standard
printer no special supplies or equipment
within minutes you're up and running
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere
you want to send
anywhere
that's what it says all right in all
caps you want to test that no i'm i'm
i'm going to test it with dams.com right
now
that's what you yeah you and also if you
go to stamp.com you get exclusive
discounts on postage
and shipping from usps and ups cut the
confusion of shipping with samples.com
new rate advisor tool you can compare
shipping rates and timelines to easily
find the best option what are we going
to do ethan we are going to save time
and money with stamps.com there's no
risk and with our promo code leftover
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free shipping at a
digital scale
no long-term commitment or contract
crazy just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in leftoverthatstamps.com
promo code leftoverstance.com never go
to the post office again
welcome back
this is our first segment
called grifton ain't easy
let's go
grifton is not easy
but it's necessary yeah
that's right so there's there's a
phenomenon on the right i mean if there
is
there's leftist grifters probably but
for sure you know
like you know [ __ ] some of them buy
houses and stuff
[ __ ] that that's a gift yeah how dare
you house yourself it's messed up dude
so so you've got the concert the
conservative grifting you've got alex
jones is the you know a great example
the dude sells slot buckets he actually
was selling kovic cures until like the
fda was like you can't do that a lot of
conservatives were yeah so you know we
have a segment dedicated to them called
grifton aide easy and this week we have
the cucks
what is the [ __ ] well let's just watch
the video when i saw this i wanted i
wanted this to be raw like i didn't want
to look it up i didn't want to pre-watch
this i wanted to see it for the first
raw yeah i'm pretty sure that's a
website yeah i wanted to be cooked raw
yeah so
ironically it actually is supposed to be
pronounced pronounced quix
it's spelled q-u-x and it stands for
quantum user experience so the the these
uh the woman who found this is a former
um infowars
millie weaver she was fired you know her
she was fired after she was arrested for
robbing her own mother so
alex jones only wants you to rob the
infowars audience
of their he's pro yeah yeah he's pro
robbing the [ __ ] out of his own audience
from their you know hard-earned
retirement funds right by selling them
like
iranian dinars or colloidal silver or
whatever the [ __ ] he's selling them
shredder you're ruining our set i spent
three million dollars on this
shredder don't
come on we're an underground bunker
he's just ripping through the bunker
that's a you know how much we spent on
that wall folks we're compromising
we got
so um
putting the crap dog in here shred are
you democrat answer now quick
joe biden sent the dog
all right here's the cuck the cucks
this has raised two hundred thousand
dollars
become dependent on a corrupted
unsecured network the so-called
worldwide stock photos this is not the
intergalactic computer network we were
promised the web makes us vulnerable to
wait i'm sorry but like this is
literally all stock photo b-roll yeah
also it's amazing also like what i
paused too much i love that no i'm i'm
the big i'm a big pauser
yeah it's just let's let it roll okay
let's let it roll for now [ __ ]
tracking any form of digital attack it's
easily gamed misused and even abused
censorship cancel culture and deep
platforming are symptoms of a larger
problem we're stuck in technological
cul-de-sacs controlled by big tech whose
interests take precedence over ours
their technology is built around
conditioning and addiction control and
domination however it doesn't have to be
this way our solution is
[Music]
q-u-x or quix is your portal to a new
digital universe
when you join quicks you have unlimited
access to whatever content you want you
can like wait pause it upload your own
wait wait hold up
what do you mean like you have unlimited
access on the internet like what kind of
[ __ ] are they trying to access
is this just for pedophiles like what's
going on yeah he's like hey you you
wanna you wanna look at some sus [ __ ]
like you wanna look at some [ __ ] that
you don't want the government finding
out i mean they definitely will see by
the way like that's the yeah the cut
well first of all this product doesn't
exist it's just an indiegogo fundraiser
it's incredible how much a b-roll from
like stock photo can get can raise you
just by grifting 170 000. that's nuts
130
1326 backers though like
can we can we see a breakdown i feel
like there's gonna be like well there
must be a and oh they they had a hundred
thousand gold they went over it oh they
crushed it bro yeah because
conservatives are very so
so here oh my goodness so you got to get
a 150 to get in the door with your own
[ __ ]
but like what it's a so so is it a
re-skinned apple tv we don't know we
actually don't know what exactly it does
wait but when you go back to the video
like the the the
the thing that like our tech overlords
don't want you to do is what grilling
meats in your [ __ ] garage did yeah
like yeah you could do that for on any
website not while getting cocked yeah i
just i don't understand well let's see
we're not even halfway through okay
she's gonna she'll explain i'm sure
music images post and listen to podcasts
quicks even allows you to use
clash of clans on that [ __ ] bro you
deserve that oh my god
they have the they have the the
sacred game that
mark that zuckerberg doesn't want you to
play angry birds
[Music]
yeah this is this is very subversive uh
desktop i love playing minecraft on my
on my cook on my cook machine
dude this is wild android apps and games
you deserve the online experience you
want to have
create collections or share new content
with your family community or the world
i love how this two couple is just other
websites volunteered to be the face of
cops they're the only people that have
used this upload
isn't a publisher it's an interface
where anyone can publish and everyone
can control their own digital experience
you can monetize your viral creations
quick space content this [ __ ] is
just
loving that grill you say
and it's really about barbecuing more
than anything
or just
they're watching themselves yeah because
they're the only people on the platform
so
so i'm i'm confused by this like okay so
like what's the argument here like you
can't be grilling meats on facebook
right that's why you got to be on cox
let me try to unpack this
it's a mysterious new gadget that's
taken the right-wing internet by storm
raised almost 200 000
from a former info awards
reporter but does it actually do
anything
um
hey we'll we'll cover this that's great
um gizmodo published an article about it
let's see if they've determined what is
this thing because of those hit pieces
hands down slander
defamation
thanks for the link bro that's great
though because it's like look notice how
so
pleasing yeah this is reverse marketing
like conservatives love when like you
know the cucks over at liberal lying
mainstream media are saying that this
product is dog [ __ ] and then this is the
griff people are buying a product they
don't even know what it does yeah but it
owns the libs and they've raised two
hundred thousand dollars just for the
idea of owning the libs a product that
doesn't exist and no one even knows what
it is yeah and it's called the [ __ ] i
mean i don't to be honest like i would
like to see the breakdown of however
many people have like given money to
this because like at least with um if
you remember like with the with the
paraplegic veteran guy who like was
working with steve bannon when they were
like funding the wall yeah like like
there was like a tangible goal there was
an end goal in sight
a lot of people that were like you know
giving money to it
i i feel like this this
this doesn't pass the smell is this
thirteen thousand not at all
thirteen thousand people have backed
like thirteen hundred or i mean not
three thousand yeah thirteen hundred
people have have gotten involved i feel
like a big chunk of that probably comes
from like one dude you know what i mean
to like juice it up a little bit well
you can um usually you can see the
amount yeah that's why i think it's like
suss that they're not showing
like oh you can see how many people
backed maybe oh so
so one thousand people oh they're
they're maxing out first edition cux box
thousand thousand maxed out yeah
one thousand we're gonna do the cux box
so you have 19 who bought the 1 000 pack
which basically means that they will
provide you a cucks pre-loaded with
child pornography
which kind of helps bypass yeah you know
that this is hard they're like it's hard
to find it so and you don't have to
download it so yeah that's how they gave
you that
yeah exactly
um listen brother libertarians this is
just their way of life you know
but i actually i just so it says
please help us figure out what the hell
this cux device for maggot lovers
actually is i mean goes moto a tech uh a
journal or website
hasn't been able to figure out what the
articles are from my friends that wrote
these articles i love that they're doing
brilliant journalism out there good job
tom
dan i know you've been looking at this
have you been able to uh uh
discern what is the point of the cuck no
like hassan said uh will is where where
i heard about this as well and um
yeah uh
there's been several articles written in
the past week since it kind of hit the
scene and
anytime
one of them reaches out to the people
behind it to try and figure out what's
going on they just
yell at them and are super hostile which
kind of tells me that
it's probably just like an amazon fire
stick well my thing when that when it
comes to you know indiegogo or kick fund
or like i mean their
fraud is basically the standard on those
websites like people will just take your
money and deliver nothing it happens
more times than not i feel like what
happens do they just like not refund
like does indiegogo just go sorry yeah
no no it's literally
indiegogo and [ __ ] kickstarter are
literally vehicles for committing fraud
oh nice i didn't know i've never been on
well either way so the the trump wall
those guys actually got busted because
they did it on gofundme they did on
gofundme but sometimes the case is
raised to the point where
uh some a district attorney will
actually investigate because it is a
crime yeah but like [ __ ] uh you know
kickstarter they give you the money and
then that's it that their job is done
yeah that that makes sense i mean look
at least they're being creative excuse
me at least they're being creative
they're not using like nfts you know the
the crypto rug pulls like everyone else
is doing like
did ayden ross gonna come out with this
next week guys
didn't soldier boy come out with his own
console
but the conservative one is like very
common this is like a super common thing
that conservatives do there was like one
kid it was like a crypto bill the first
crypto millionaire or whatever it was
like 14 or something uh he had a freedom
phone i don't know if you saw this the
freedom phone oh this is exactly the
same [ __ ] so the freedom phone was
basically like a alibaba drop shipping
campaign for huawei phones that are like
literally less secure
than a regular android you could buy a
chinese backdoor oh yeah yeah well not
just chinese backdoor it's like easily i
think it's like easily hackable too
and it's basically just like rewrite the
apps
and say like you could have all of your
banned apps on this like that liberals
don't want you it's like dude they're
going to make money off you either way
and also okay moment that you put a sim
card in your phone
it's over like everybody knows where you
are
well here's an article about it yeah i
mean this is the grift ladies and
gentlemen and you're going to see it
week after week and there's a video for
this too this dude bitcoin millionaire
eric finnman announces the freedom phone
it's a genius man
yeah that's what i'm saying if you
didn't care and you just wanted to make
money grifting conservatives is
definitely the way to do it yeah they
got they got deep pockets they are
easily motivated okay
they're super easily motivated they will
immediately like they have a lot of they
have a lot of disposable income
and they're willing to like you know
consume stuff that makes a political
statement you know what i mean so
it's it's a super easy way to
oh so here what if i don't receive my
perk
indiegogo is unable to guarantee that
projects will succeed or that perks will
even be delivered or deemed satisfactory
so there you go yeah griff secured yeah
just don't go on indiegogo
yes i was reading your friend's article
um
where'd it go i was getting to this
point where it says well what is this
device
and uh i wanted to read that paragraph
so what does it do according to the
promotional video everything and nothing
users will have unlimited access to
whatever content you want as well as the
ability to upload and share all kinds of
content the closest it comes to a hard
explanation is that cuck is an interface
where anyone can publish and control
control their digital
creations and also makes money somehow
via affiliate advertising who's who's
like
people are fighting one another to get
on the cox network on the advertising
side
like
it's just because michael pillow bought
all of them like it's just i i assume
the only person who'd be like in the box
here is mike pillow
you know
i mean
there's i mean listen you have a
goalable
wealthy market i mean it's kind of prime
dollars
anyway shout out to the [ __ ]
yeah apparently wait what they have 500
subs on youtube
yeah we got we got their youtube channel
oh there you go dude
give me one maybe we'll get some info
link us there's no shot we're going to
get additional information from this
youtube channel come on don't be scared
don't be such a
nobody's just a coach don't be such
shaming now oh okay the comments are
pretty good hold on cux logo in space
come on bro
this says it all
200 000 on indiegogo
any questions
isn't that
what what yeah i have more questions now
any
any questions every single video you've
shown me thus far
leads to more questions okay hold the
criticism for this one first look at the
cucks
little star wars music yeah why what's
going on why is this so like dangerous
like why why do they have to market this
is like
the future is now this may this
this
made two hundred thousand dollars
yo it's so easy dude it's crazy it's not
tv baby man it's it's
i love i love how like these [ __ ]
dummies think they they're they're you
know they're not sheep
like that's why they're on the cucks
network right which doesn't exist and
will never exist no shots network i
think there is already a cucks network
and you have to be 18 to uh yeah
here's their here's the response
cox is a universal media box where all
media is accessible and shareable within
a private encrypted network
and accessible to anyone outside the
network it's like signal
but for entertainment in a private
marketplace bro what are you saying so
basically what they want to do is like
gab but where you can you know share
videos and like maybe make money is it
just
but it's like a social feels like a
streaming uh platform at the same time
it's a private marketplace
the thing is all of these like
all of these like conservative only or
like you know these freedom lover
networks they always uh end up turning
into what gab is which is a network for
white supremacist nazis
files and sometimes both like you know
right right because like you know that's
what happens when you don't have any
restriction like it's well that's the
only people that have any reason to be
there yeah exactly so yeah so cox is
monetized through advertising and
transaction fees in the marketplace so
yeah it's basically
uh
facebook
plus
roku
meets
file nazis yeah
and it's like
so if you're a final nazi like this is
for you right
but
you know
i don't know how many of them are out
there probably not at all i think
there's 1300 yeah i mean approximately
yeah i don't think that like you know
advertisers are going to want to go on
the
nazi network can you promote can you
promote child free or no
no oh okay it is super cool
okay because i was just thinking that
would be a good
vertical that would be yeah the the
creators of child for you are like oh
finally but
um
the thing is like the other reason why
this misses the mark completely
is because they refuse to acknowledge
that a big reason why conservatives love
twitter and [ __ ] like that is because
they get to [ __ ] own the libs right
and if they're just like sitting in a
broom with a bunch of other sweaty neck
beards who are into the same [ __ ] that
they're into they're like well this
sucks there's no [ __ ] living
yeah that's why all those other like
conservative like
competitor networks fail ultimately
because they can't bring on libs to own
onto that platform if they could bully
some liberals on like gab that should be
popping off
so it's no fun for them when they're
just like amongst themselves talking
like oh yeah like
i love you know i love donald trump
right like it's it gets boring after a
while just read to oh they're all like i
love donald yeah retweet yeah no i feel
you i think that's exactly right it's so
sad though like this is i mean i feel
bad a little bit this is
well you know it's not as damaging as
like ivermectin like believing that the
vaccine is fake and then [ __ ] you
know right that's another grift
investigate so here's um investigate
cucks
this is irobot
and hassan has infiltrated
that's right network that's right i'm in
there i'm in the mainframe damn you guys
whipped that up we found the lib to own
first of all that's that's that's
graphic design at the same level as the
cucks network oh yeah like that's that's
basically this tops everything they put
out in the advertising this is this got
real like graphics design is my passion
vibes
well there you go you know we we operate
at a high level here at the number one
for uh number 14 podcast in the world
ladies and gentlemen yeah all right
listen uh speaking of number 14 and
podcasting i got to take a dump real
fast wait really yeah okay i'm sorry
it's all good all right let's take out
let's take a dump break we are back i
apologize for doing that to you it's all
good i have that ashkenazi
what happened you have some you have
some dairy
i had to drop a dairy i had one drop of
dairy are you are you like those
actually i'm not
oh you're so lucky i mean i'm not either
but i
i have so many friends that are lactose
intolerant i'm like if that happens to
me i don't know like no i i i'm actually
not which is weird because amongst my
brethren the ashkenazi jews i think i'm
like the one-eyed king uh the one-eyed
man in the world of the blind or yeah
you are yeah yeah that's me you you i
tell everyone how the ice cream tastes
yeah
uh all right moving on the herman cain
awards
this is a huge hot topic issue here yeah
we're talking about covid
actually we have a stinger because we
were going to make this a reoccurring
segment so what i want to discuss is can
we make this a reoccurring segment or is
it too spicy let's take a look
roll the stinger
[Music]
okay so that stinger is fire thank you
but
the way i the way i see it like
um for me
i
usually
like i rip heavy into like conservative
commentators who get coveted and die
like
after god rips into them i'm i'm taking
one too you know what i mean yeah i'm
taking god's sloppy seconds there
cause like those guys are pieces of [ __ ]
like even if they themselves are victims
of misinformation because like you know
tucker carlson's not [ __ ] dying you
know
yeah he's backs the [ __ ] up he's like
greg abbott you know what i mean greg
happ is not taking chances like he he's
uh he's has like eight different kinds
of booster shots already probably in it
well and then look at someone who's not
vaccinated like joe rogan and he says on
the show once he got covered he had like
a whole procedure with some crooked-ass
doctor he paid to give him like every
stupid unverified medicine plus plus
regenerons yeah yeah monoclonal
antibodies which is like what trump got
so like even yeah the people that are
peddling the misinformation that's
getting people killed
yeah do you think you see when they die
so when they die i celebrate it right
for sure i mean i'm i'm a horrible
person so don't don't you know
i'm not exactly a good example
but i do feel
weird a little bit when it comes to
people that are just like random
casuals you know what i mean some
facebook post stuff some dude in ohio
unless they're like somewhat of a
community leader or they have like
influence or they just like go balls to
the wall
you know what i mean like they they've
like prevented others actively from
getting the vaccine or something like
that
then i'm like
okay like you know i'll
i'll engage in this a little bit so
let me give some context herman cain
obviously uh
of godfather pizza
was he was running to be he was actually
doing quite well
2016 again right uh when when everyone
was running against trump yeah
and he was a prominent uh republican
during that psycho somehow
and anyway
he made this all this hubbub about going
to one of trump's events one of his
his first ever oklahoma rally his rally
in the middle of covid when you know the
pandemic was popping off and trump
wanted to make a big deal about having
an indoor rally in no masks
it's a full yeehaw they made everyone
sign a waiver though beforehand to be
like if you die it's like and guess who
did die
yeah boy herman [ __ ] kane and so
herman cain went to this event got
covered and straight up [ __ ] died
yeah and so
there now has a bit from birth like a
phoenix from his ashes not he was not
reborn he's still dead he's still the
meme was reborn from his ashes a hermit
crane award but his twitter account is
still posting vacations
his twitter account kept posting vex
not vaccine but like covet misinfo
for
like like posthumously they were just
like straight up still like yeah i
remember
like the day after he died his account
was posting covet misinfo like as he was
dying on his death dying yeah so there
so the so you know there's worse thing
is they never even like brought him up
like they treated him like a like a
background character like an extra in a
movie did they literally
[ __ ] like
swept his corpse into a ditch and just
cemented him over like did trump i don't
even know if trump ever mentioned herman
cain like uh he was good he was a good
man he was weak he was weak that's why
covert got him but he was good
i beat him and then kevin beat him i
beat toad
i'm so powerful
so anyway here is the
herman cain awards now there's been some
controversy even among lefties saying
it's in poor taste let's take a look at
some i have an opinion about all this
let's take a look at some of the top
posts of all time okay let's do it i
mean number one of course is the man
himself nobody can ever uh dethrone
detune him
uh don't believe everything you hear on
fake news i never had the wuhan flu
because it doesn't exist of course he
died of covet so that to me is like
you know i mean come on i mean that's
that's too perfect you have to make fun
of that that should be his that should
be honestly engraved yeah on his
tombstone yeah
yeah no i agree so this is valid you can
you can make fun of that and it's fun
and like let's be honest the man died
it's funny like i'm just sorry but it is
it's just i'm sorry to say that and
death is tragic and sad but this man's
death also had uh there was an element
of you know humor in it as well rarely
do you ever see
someone read what they sell
so it is
especially like evil people especially
people that are like spreading vaccine
misinformation spreading coveted
misinformation that is like actually
leading to
hundreds if not thousands of people like
also getting blinded by that
misinformation rarely do you ever see
people like that
um you know see the consequences of
at least a fraction of their damage
that's why i personally am in favor of
the hermann kane award
as bleak as it is
these are real people that are dying
that we're you know laughing at but i do
think it's important like you were
saying
that people see this is real like
there's before covet conservatives would
deny reality in so many different ways
and and but in the in the specific way
of this pandemic you can't you can deny
it all you want but it's real and it's
gonna [ __ ] kill you and i think that
that there's nothing raises that point
better than this i mean this is just one
of nine ignore the outrage ignore the
thugs defy the violence tonight's tulsa
trump rally where he [ __ ] died
well cop yeah get got the vid he got got
yeah we'll be one for the history books
america's here tonight baby these crowds
are unbelievable it was so funny because
america was not there like even people
in oklahoma were like
i don't know if i want to see trump that
bad you know what i mean like it was
empty like the crowds were not there you
know and it was so bad i remember
because i was you know i still cover
trump all the time i miss him a lot
um and he'll be back greatest president
of all be back he's definitely running
you agree oh for sure yeah yeah greatest
person you think you'll get the nom
oh yeah he'll destroy who else are gonna
get desantis yeah no shot he he will
destroy every single person in his way
desantis do is it worth the is it worth
the civil war to bring trump back for
the memes
no no of course not oh i don't know i
thought you might say yes no no
absolutely not i mean he's he's homes
are important he's a monster i don't i
don't care i wish we could i wish they
would just like you know let joe biden
do his thing you know
do the mac attack run around be old and
[ __ ] silly so we could have some more
joe vitamins but like they're keeping
him a [ __ ] hyperbaric chamber or
whatever
he's getting right like right right for
the three minutes that he's on camera
he's like
all right jack yeah and then and then
they [ __ ] roll him into a [ __ ] vat
and he's like cryogenically freezing
yeah in between
yeah i love that only to be let out for
ice cream uh here's just a few of the
black voices for trump
we are sorry to announce that herman
cain has tested positive for coven 19 as
currently receiving treatment please
keep him in your prayers [ __ ]
why are you asking me to prayer you
could have just worn a mask and now i
gotta pray not to go to the [ __ ]
tulsa alley i'm sorry now god obviously
wanted you to get coveted was my prayers
gonna do yeah his design yeah i can't go
against god dude i'm not praying for
that
and then the press secretary herman cain
embodied the american dream and
represent the very best of the american
spirit
oh my god our three for his loved ones
and they will remain in our prayers at
this time we will never forget his
legacy that's a lie
you guys never
only kaylee mackenzie the only tweet
yeah
it's crazy because he made the ultimate
sacrifice for trump he went there and
died for that man yeah it's awesome
trump doesn't even remember him
right so sad herman cain he was a great
man uh uh uh
died tragedy
yeah died tragically not good well i
mean deleted tweet from hermitage
doing what he loved you know being a
fall guy for the trump administration
and the conservative cause like that's
what that's what his goal was that's
what he wanted to do you know and uh
that's that's what happened apparently
he to he erased this tweet it looks like
the virus is not as deadly as the
mainstream media first made it out to be
rip the virus killed you you died from
it and this is
man herman cain was being killed by his
pandemic and then later tweeting after
he died yeah that the pandemic isn't
really that deadly yeah it's the most
important thing to happened in 2020 yeah
their team was just like no we got to
keep going with this
yo
they tweeted that after he died
yeah no way crazy the team was the fight
they were membing ah that's the craziest
[ __ ] i ever [ __ ] read people are ride
or die like they're that's the sound
it's like the virus is not as deadly as
the media made it out to be
you literally died yeah
so so it feels good when i like i mean
i'm not gonna deny it it feels great
that might that's the best
this is the best case yeah so i'll give
you an argument as to why and i've
talked about this a lot like i'll give
you an argument as to why
this is good to do i just read the
second one correct maybe off topic for
everyone's laughs what is it covered
early treatment experience i ever met
then uh ivor mexton saved my best
friend's life i'm here to share this
story and then uh later on i'd love to
hear the story a few months ago i found
out my best friend was sleeping with my
wife i was dedicated and absolutely
filled with rage but the week before i
planned on murdering him i was diagnosed
with covet since i am not vaccinate i
took ivermectin to treat it it did not
work at all i'm now in the hospital and
can barely walk let alone kill my best
friend i've ever met and saved his life
it's true
there you go a little minor victory
there
but
but what i was going to say is this if
you want
if you want like a good argument here's
what it is
conservatives are reactionary so they
are motivated by like pure anger and
hatred misplaced anger
uh
towards like liberals right they hate
the systems they're oppressive but then
they like you know redirect that anger
to the common enemy that they have which
is liberals lip tarts right
so
this kind of like celebration i think
should be
cause for them to go out and get the
vaccine because like you don't want to
get owned by life hey you don't want me
to [ __ ] own you dude because i own
you like i will make fun of you if you
die i'm going to make fun of you so you
think the fear of getting owned by libs
is more
urgent to them than
covid 1 million yeah interesting
absolutely so i always tell them like
listen you know if you got if you got
like
parents that are afraid of vaccines or
whatever because they're like victims of
misinformation there's different ways of
dealing with that but if you have like a
die hard like republican ass you know
mom and dad just show them like i'm
everything that they despise about
america you know what i mean like
like muslim dude who's been in the
country since you know only been in the
country since like 20 uh i mean 2008
2009
and you know i'm i'm a [ __ ]
anti-capitalist you know what i mean i
i'm a die-hard anti-realist you don't
want me laughing at you i will laugh and
worst of all you're going to tap dance
on their graves yeah exactly i will own
you like you will be owned i mean
honestly anything to get people
vaccinated at this point
so here here's some of the ones from
this week
capital insurrectionist dies from covid
um they said
december 7th i'll do it this way
coronavirus
vaccine thumbs down
sure i'll take the vaccine
uh just mail it to me my health and
safety is too important to show up in
person just like mail and voting you
know okay so they're doing the whole
thing mail in voting yada yada
who in texas is going tomorrow to dc
my body is going they're driving hold
the line oh this is january 6th yeah
just think about right now just wait
till there's 73 more million more of us
yeah every trump voter is ready to storm
the capital yeah totally check this out
richard shows the
guess who the first ceo of moderna was a
cornell graduate named anthony fauci
dude i'm not reading this whole thing
yadda yadda more come on take the jab
what are you english
i don't i just i don't know country lady
why do they i don't know why i mean they
just they got to put a little flavor on
it they got a seasoning on that you know
i'm putting everyone on notice if i walk
into a restaurant bar exerter and you
ask me for proof of vaccine i will
immediately file suit against you i will
file both a personal and business
lawsuit for violation of my hippa laws
baby it's like
it's just like so funny like
libertarians oftentimes find the the
funniest way to be like the most
annoying like
they are the most like rule-loving rule
breakers you know what i mean like i'm
gonna use the rules in my favor to like
debate you it's like dude [ __ ] chill
i mean the hip the hippo was one of my
favorite things that came up wasn't it
yeah she goes uh they go are you
vaccinated and you know she is yeah and
so she goes uh that's a violation of my
hipaa rights i was like
that's not how that works you're not a
doctor dumbass it's like doctor patient
confidentiality like that's not you know
just imagine reporting yourself as being
such a dumbass
but it doesn't matter because they they
revel in it like conservatives love that
[ __ ] they don't care they just like they
think she's brave hipaa yeah they don't
really care about how to use the law as
long as they're again owning the libs
she thinks she's got hipaa rights
i think she has got hippo rights got him
hypocrite not a hippo damn you i would
never make fun of a woman's appearance i
do all the time for martial
green she looks like a titan from
attackers i know it's like that meme is
so good for you guys that haven't seen
that i'll just hold up going on with
your gun someone sent it to me because
that that [ __ ] out go to a doctor you
know
you got [ __ ] up gums
so
if you making it do you use do you make
an exception for her to make fun of her
looks
i mean who's gonna you know what people
always say like you're body shaming like
what if i look like marjorie taylor
green it's like no you don't no one
looks like her she literally looks like
a titan are you a titan
like chill but also it's like i mean i
get it though i get it people get mad
they're like oh when you're body shaming
someone like that you're you're
technically making fun of someone that
could look like that and it's like dude
just let me have fun please the titan
analogy is undeniable yeah it's just
like just let me have some fun
if someone got that titan meme and
discard yeah i'm trying to find one
that's like a side by side i guess
you'd like probably if you google like
margaery titan green
well anyway i'm pretty sure sherry's
about to die we're getting close to the
end
the virus was used on purpose the
election was stolen
yadda yadda you get the idea if you come
to my door and try to force me to get
vacs it's not gonna happen
yeah why do democrats support mandatory
vaccine and mass for american citizens
but not illegal aliens okay i mean is
that found it in your own tweet yeah
there you go if you yeah like i said if
you google margery titan green looking
ass like yeah she does look like a titan
yeah that is unbelievably active she
behaves like one too it's crazy
she's just she's just
madness dude i mean she's like a real
estate developer yoga mom crossfit lady
who
is now
i don't know i mean i just i don't
understand how the she is a politician
isn't she isn't she like the biggest
fundraiser in the republican party right
now she's that makes sense i mean she's
raising like millions anyway sherry's
about to die um okay this is where it
gets good
so
uh her last post was um i knew it had to
be a corrupt scheme to cause the proper
trials to be skipped it's not safe yadda
yadda update on sherry
she's in dialysis now
they did go back in late last night to
replace the port ventilator is still
doing all of her breathing for her
they're also starting her on a feeding
tube today
update on sherry her oxygen levels at
90.
that's the only improvement she's taking
everything well and we'll keep her like
this for at least two weeks
these [ __ ] psychos some days are just
really hard my sister sherry lost her
battle with covid
the problem is like these psychos now
think like
i see so many tweets from these [ __ ]
people and it's like they say stuff like
it's a conspiracy like why are all these
truth tellers dying it's like
i wonder why dude i wonder why they're
you know all the covet denialists are
are [ __ ] dying they're saying there's
an assassination plot and not just that
the pandemic that everybody's saying is
real didn't run it's it's not course it
can't be that and it's like so but the
question is this is a woman who's
getting like 20 likes on facebook
yeah probably not making an impact in
the world around her that much
obviously very obnoxious she's like in
deep with the covet stuff she ends up
dying of covid
i think it's a worthy cautionary tale
i really do think it's worth sharing now
do i think you know this
the herman cain is obviously in a pla in
a position of influence whereas you know
uh sherry from bum [ __ ]
is not
no i don't know about like stop like tap
dancing on their grave necessarily but
this story is compelling i don't know
what do you think so
um
i i i don't go after cases like this
like i don't cover cases like this
normally on my show on my broadcast
because i just don't really care
like doesn't it's like a low impact you
know what i mean like like you said 20
people saw it and then they died and she
died and now her family's sad and you
know some of them are probably
anti-vaxxers too and that kind of stuff
well the truth is she's more a victim
herself of of the grift of people like
alex jones and or crowder or whoever all
these uh whoever these [ __ ]
right-wing people that are grifting on
all this fear the only problem is like
when people like that die they're not
going out alone like the issue that i
always have with people like this is
like listen if you're gonna [ __ ] die
in your own apartment you know because
you
can no longer breathe and you need a
ventilator and you're not going to take
up icu like already exhausted limited
icu capabilities by those lying doctors
that you think were like assassinating
people in the in the beginning of the
pandemic like they were just like making
up these insane experiences all of a
sudden yeah you know well it's funny how
she's posting all these posts and then
suddenly she's trusting a doctor to
shove a tube down
there was an anti there was a covert
denial or there's a vaccine
misinformation spreading guy that they
actually pulled out of the er and then
he immediately he died
like this happened i mean this happens
frequently
um
i remember uh what's that guy
in georgia that was leading the uh
the the georgia recall and like don't
vote for
don't vote for the georgian republicans
like movement
lynn
something lynn i'm forgetting he's like
a it's like an ex-democrat who's a
lawyer he was calling up hospitals to be
like you need to give ivermectin and the
doctor's like dude shut the [ __ ] up i'm
a doctor like i know what i'm doing and
this guy's like we will sue you if you
don't give ivermectin to our friend and
then that person's like they're all
gonna die like of course they're gonna
die
and um
people like that i don't have a problem
with i mean i'll make fun of them all
day every day
it's a matter of like
are you
grifting people or are you the victim of
a griff yeah that i think makes the
difference well even the grifters
themselves are technically even the
grifters themselves are technically
victims if they're dying of covid
because like
like the am radio the am radio broadcast
uh people that die
they probably don't think that tucker
carlson got the vaccine they have to
believe their own [ __ ] you know what i
mean sure because like why wouldn't you
take the bag i guess it's like a pyramid
scheme in a way where you have like
tucker and hannity exactly like that and
they know it's they those guys are i
behind the scenes they are they are yeah
100 percent aware of everything is it
ninety-five
fascinated
yeah no they have a vaccination policy
you have to be vaccinated to go into the
studio yeah which is by the way ironic
because they also hate vaccine mandates
it's like they are under a vaccine
mandate it works that's why you got
vaccinations if you look at tucker and
hannity and all these guys these are
multi multi-millionaires
astute businessman they got someone
educated highly educated probably in
both their cases fully vaccinated and
they really are just that's the grift
yeah that's the gift right there are
more like
honestly confused and scared
vaccine hesitant like hollywood
celebrities than there are conservative
commentators conservative commentators
are not like genuinely vaccine hesitant
they especially ones at the top
they know
they absolutely know that you know these
things work
and they also trump himself got the
vaccine like before it was even publicly
available yeah they know that the
vaccine works um
they know that their audience is
skeptical of the vaccine and this is a
great way because conservatives love
reading the room like conservative
commentators conservative politicians
they know how to captivate their
audience right
by going along with the dumb [ __ ] that
their audience wants and like really
leaning into it i think that's right and
i think part of what steers them in that
direction too is that whenever you
deviate from what they want to hear
there's a riot for example um sean
hannity was like yo people you should
get vaccinated he did and then like the
next episode he had to come back and be
like only if you want to like i'm not
about that like they booed trump at his
rally yeah um that's the first time that
like you know it's the only time that
trump ever gets booed is when he's like
get the vaccine i guess it's a great
vaccine i made the vaccine yeah even
then
what does it mean they've created a
monster they've lost control of or they
just you know
well they just don't i think they just
don't care and what i mean by that is
like
they
like i said they they would rather
captivate
and and enrage and galvanize an audience
uh then then fear the consequences of
that they don't care if people die
because ultimately like
they're they're already gonna win
regardless even if they're the minority
as they are conservatives are the
minority in this country
um there are less republican voters in
this country than there are democratic
voters but the system is designed in a
way to still allow conservatives a
victory those who own capital in this
country control every facet of
government they've designed the system
historically to benefit their needs
and uh every facet of information
including the media is there to churn
out results that normalize the
oppression that we face
when i say we i mean you and i are we we
are very successful and very lucky to
have made it out of that oh that looked
[ __ ] up yeah that did we you want to
do it again
we have to do it fake
there you go
yeah nailed it um
but yeah we
like the the working class is is
experiencing a [ __ ] load of uh weird
struggles that they don't need to
but our current organization of the
economy has has made it the normal thing
and you look at the media you look at
everything and everything is reinforcing
that oppression as like a normal thing
and that's what that that's what the
media is there for that's what every
facet of entertainment is there for
and
it's all there to churn out outcomes
that benefit those who own capital
and so there is there is that breakdown
there is that difference
wealthy people in the corporations own
everything
and um
but i just know i do wonder if they just
like psychopaths or they just i don't
know here let's look at craigs i mean i
think they they are also born into the
system they think it's normal they think
it's like totally
normal to just like make as much money
as possible no i know but like don't you
have to be a like you have to be like a
real [ __ ] psychopath to say to be
sean hannity to beat tucker carlson to
go to work in an office that has a
literal vaccine mandate to be vaccinated
to sit there and then
fear monger about the vaccine that you
use and benefit from that you know works
i think you get used to it after a while
probably i mean they've been lying about
[ __ ] for years they probably tell
themselves i'm just doing entertainment
i'm just telling people that they want
to literally legally say that in court
cases yeah so
it's the same thing that like mediums do
they like they mediums people can't talk
to ghosts okay yeah sorry spoiler and
but but people a lot of people
rationalize it
like good otherwise normal people say
hey they're just telling the people what
they want to hear and it's like well you
know
okay comforting them they're comforting
they're comforting victims exactly
that's what they say yeah but it's it's
a grift yeah and i think that sean
hannity and tucker probably tell
themselves the same thing
yeah and also that um they might despise
the the liberals or whatever too on top
of that but i think after a while it's
just the routine like it's yeah you can
i just like to pick they're gonna use
their brain to have an honest
conversation just understand the rat
because you know they rationalize stuff
i just love to hear what they tell
themselves yeah craig thought kovid was
dumb and over-hyped made fun of masks
and foxes craig is dead his brother is
dead his mother is dead all within a
month
i mean it's devastating horrible but it
but i chuckled while reading that yeah i
mean
this is like this is the stuff that i
don't normally cover like i don't really
i don't really care there's a lot of
people like craig out there who just
like it sucks that this happened to them
yeah i understand why some of these
posts would be not necessarily
newsworthy you know but it's just like a
random dude you know i mean let's see
craig cc now recommends wearing a seat
belt even when you're outside the car
that's exactly what the vaccine is right
like
yadda yadda vaccine misinfo and then
here's his obituary you know it's
actually not it's that this is actually
[ __ ] horribly tragic
uh his whole goddamn family got wiped
out by kovid yeah that's just sad
so these people are victims of
misinformation and i think that like i
would rather redirect the anger
uh towards those like talker carlson and
the am radio talk show hosts like the
conservative broadcasters that are
pumping this kind of misinformation
those like brett weinstein even and like
those red wine scenes these other like
dartmouth boys dark horse based vodka oh
my [ __ ] god dude it's like it makes
me so mad these these [ __ ] clowns
dude they're like
it's so obvious that
being a snake oil salesman now
is profitable even if you're not selling
snake oil
it's the fact that like
you are subversive and you are breaking
the mold and you're you have that secret
solution exactly that other people just
it's like other people just aren't
willing to see the truth you don't have
to you don't have to
there's no upfront cost you don't have
to like actually sell ivermectin just
saying that like ivermectin is a secret
treatment the government is high so many
engaged people exactly they're a captive
audience you can sell them uh there was
i was watching sam cedar when he was
showing brett weinstein when he started
hawking ivermektum and he this was
really fascinating also you know
maybe it was you i was watching it could
have been me you showed you it was you i
was watching you showed his patreon
followers skyrocketed once he started
hawking that [ __ ] and i was like
[ __ ] yeah it like doubled yeah
of course and then he went on joe rogan
and he was cancelled and then you know
he goes on jewelry and then he
immediately put out a book
and
you know that's just the way they make
their money it's really gross it's
really really gross especially because
like i don't think brett weinstein
legitimately believes that ivermectin is
a is a cure is a treatment
what's there to believe the company that
makes ivermectin literally put out a
statement and said do not use this for
treatment and covet is not proven in
fact it may even be harmful and um
why would the company put out a
statement like that if they could make
money if there was even a shred of doubt
of viability for it to treat covet they
would stand to make a shitload of
[ __ ] money just doing that but like
everybody is saying it doesn't help
and not to mention that people are
taking ivermectin who can't get it from
doctors because any sane doctor is not
going to prescribe it so they say okay
[ __ ] you well brett weinstein and joe
rogan and everyone said this is cool so
they got them down of tractor supplies
get a tube of this [ __ ] and [ __ ] out
their [ __ ] intestines bro literally
[ __ ] out there and test it i'm gonna
tell you something right now
do you want to know why this is all all
fake [ __ ] okay because like people
always talk about like fize i just
figured out my intestines well during
that short break you want you want to
know what's going on here okay this is
what i tell people all the time there
were 13 companies that were contracted
by operation warp speed and training 20
13 companies seven of them said yes
unfortunately he's behind the [ __ ]
paywall so i can't i don't know what the
exact what the seventh i've been tested
three times i'm getting over a minor
illness sorry okay no it's all good so
yeah operation warp speed announced the
finalists of the of its funding
initiative
um out of the uh out of the the uh
finalists the only ones that were
you know in the emergency authorization
the ones that got emergency
authorization that were viable
were moderna
the biontech which we know is pfizer
and in the united states at least and
also johnson and johnson which is not an
mrna vaccine normal vaccine just like a
regular vaccine by the way footnote
there for everyone that's like skeptical
about the vaccine like joe rogan and all
these dip ships to talk circle jerk just
get the johnson johnson as a normal
[ __ ] vaccine you [ __ ] yeah it's
heads exactly but they don't want that
either five people out of stroke because
they're they're skeptical of the the
vaccine in general um and that's the
reality
candidates included are not using
traditional approaches to vaccine
development like inactivated or subunit
vaccines also not included as a
candidate developed by sanofi and
glaxosmithkline
and all of these other companies merck
also had their own
do you know why nobody talks about merck
gsk or or sanofi
because their [ __ ] vaccines didn't
work so obviously that's precisely the
reason why the fda did not give them
emergency users they wish they could
have gotten that exactly they all they
all try to develop something and the
ones that worked we're we're using now
yeah and that's what frustrates me about
this is like if you legitimately were if
you legitimately think the government's
like lying to all of us then why the
[ __ ] do they waste billions of dollars
on like seven pharmaceutical
corporations and only have three
vaccines available
yeah i uh
brett weinstein and all these
ivormectemhawks that their old grand
theory doesn't make any sense on any
level
yeah it doesn't they say that you know
you can't trust big pharma totally valid
i mean understand max but murphy's
that's big pharma that's as big as it
gets so why do you trust well they don't
even trust merc when merck is like
right you know they have we
trust the drug we don't trust the
statement yeah damn it and it's so
stupid and we tried to get our hands on
some horse face but it's sold out
everywhere really we tried to buy a tube
of horse base you cannot [ __ ] buy
this [ __ ] everywhere they're literally
horses and farm animals that cannot get
treated for this calm they have common
parasites that are usually irretrievable
and they're [ __ ] hordes of people
that's using this [ __ ] like toothpaste
yeah
and these poor farm animals are it can't
be treated and most of the uh most of
the ivermectin
information comes from a bunch of faulty
studies one that was on that was done on
rats which have which is normal
rats and humans actually have like very
similar
uh
systems so like a lot of the
the test subjects are rats oftentimes
but um that study if i remember
correctly off the top of my head um
yielded inclusive results for humans
because the level of of um ivermectin
that you would need for a human would
cause you to actually overdose on it so
they dropped that and then the main
study that showed that ivermectin was
actually good as a viable coveted
treatment
that was subsequently then used on
multiple other meta studies that one was
pulled back because it was faulty data
inputs like they just [ __ ] lied about
ivermectin's viability in the results
and they do this all the [ __ ] they do
the same thing with global warming they
take one test they take one data set
that was like retracted or debunked
totally and they'll just [ __ ] run the
whole thing they did the same thing with
autism with vaccines too yeah they did
that they take one [ __ ] test and they
won't ever shut the [ __ ] up about it it
was a this is actually a funny story
it's a disgraced former doctor in the uk
andrew wakefield
that um that made that faulty study for
an american lawsuit
uh that said that uh the mmr
vaccine was causing autism in children
um because of like uh some
gastrointestinal issues that it was
causing that study was completely
fabricated there was actually like
literal child abuse occurring in the
study
okay because he was like doing um
colonoscopies on children
without like getting like prior parental
consent informed consent from their
parents
really traumatizing [ __ ] yeah and the uk
immediately was like this is ridiculous
turns out the reason why he was doing it
of course was also because he was
shilling his own vaccine which was um
just a separated mmr vaccine he was
selling them individually like he wanted
the government to use that and sell that
um
and guess what the uk they uh took away
his license practice medicine yeah he
now lives in a [ __ ] fat compound in
austin and continues the [ __ ] uh you
know they moved to america he moved to
became a hero he's [ __ ] chasing
millions exactly on cruises he goes on
anti-vaxx cruisers which is so ironic
it's like a backpack
man i've put them all on a cruise yeah
hold on there's a fly here
oh [ __ ] you missed it but yeah he
he has a model girlfriend
he lives in a [ __ ] what's his name
let me see what he said andrew wakefield
model girlfriend has like
let's see what his girlfriend looks like
um no she's famous oh for real yeah she
is a famous model girlfriend what the
[ __ ] i think they might have broken up
now oh i'm so sorry ella mcpherson yeah
is this [ __ ] vaccinated what do
you think
i don't know probably
he probably is he probably is they
probably both are yeah this dude is like
having sex with like hotties in his way
[ __ ] how is he making money now what
how's he making money now just anti-vac
[ __ ] he goes he's a speaker for
anti-vaxx he's the king of anti-vaxx
who
he's doing
unsanctioned child experiments sounds
like he should be in jail for that yeah
well the uk didn't hit him hard enough
they just like took away his license and
then america welcomed him with open arms
because we are
[ __ ] idiots texas has been waiting
for you
it makes me ha
okay so finally actually we have our hog
of the week we're going to wrap it up
okay
this is this is a segment i want to do
every week
where we nominate the worst person of
the week
and this week is none other than our boy
is it in the is it in the stinger or do
i need to say the name
you got to say the name tucker carlson
he's
it's hard to beat him even on a week by
week basis go ahead roll the stinger
[Music]
all right a little abrupt there the
ending huh yeah
we'll work on that yeah that's a work in
progress turtle cross is a hagga every
week he's the he's the champion this is
our boy tucker carlson in prime time
television straight up giving white
nationalists
kkk talking points prime time fox news
baby let's go talking about the great
replacement and eugenics of all things
we love that for him an unrelenting
stream of immigration but why well joe
biden just said it to change the racial
mix of the country that's the reason to
reduce the political power of people
whose ancestors lived here and
dramatically increase the proportion of
americans newly arrived from the third
world
and then produce the world he said that
non-white dna is the quote source of our
strength
imagine saying that
this is the language of eugenics it's
horrifying
but there's a reason biden said it in
political terms this policy is called
the great replacement the replacement of
legacy americans well there's no way joe
biden said any of that no uh there's a
video of it he says something like
diversity is our strength which is the
american melting pot it's something
we've said since day one yeah it's 100
true yeah it's like one of the we used
to and one of the only good things about
american yeah i would say
uh but also he's going to bastardize
that and and say that like this is
eugenics which is ironic because he then
follows that up with the great
replacement which is a nazi conspiracy
that's like white people are being
eradicated you shall not replace us yeah
exactly and and that's like straight
white supremacist rhetoric right oh yeah
but for people that don't understand
this i need to i need to like you know
take a step back because tucker carlson
is very good at
white washing white nativist white
nationalists white supremacists talking
points and making it seem like he's just
a nice little dish
he's saying like wow joe biden is trying
to do eugenics by you know eradicating
white people so
you know what eradicates white people
you know what white suprema you know
what the great replacement is
miscegenation
race mixing
and people like tucker carlson [ __ ]
hate that but that is the reason why the
white population is decreasing
that and also because whiteness is a
concept based on exclusion based on
purity it comes from the one drop rule
which means that like if you have one
drop of non-white blood
black blood specifically that means you
are no longer white that's why despite
the fact that obama is half white we
don't consider him to be another white
president we consider him to be the
first black president right because
because whiteness is a concept and i
have to repeat this is built around
purity the purity of the white gene
also what does whiteness even mean i
mean whiteness has no specific
origin i mean you're talking about
like a multitude of cultures and people
and identities it literally just means
yeah like you said white purity so
that's and it's also a concept that is
always expanded whiteness is just a
substitute for power this is like
it just means like the in-group the
group that holds the power and
when immigration or miscegenation you
know black people and white people
having sex with one another consensually
uh which is the thing that tucker
carlson hates i cannot stress this
enough you need to understand this this
is what racist people [ __ ] hate okay
they won't say
calm yeah it's just yeah exactly i mean
they love that [ __ ] they love jerking
off to it they love watching it but not
but nope but no
but um if she gets pregnant do we board
or not
oh for their they probably abort all
that [ __ ] but
the point i was trying to make is like
they
they are um
they the the concept of whiteness is is
so
uh malleable and so interchangeable and
and not like a solid thing
that
i mean there are historically so many
groups of people that were not
considered white i'm not considered
white but i'm white as [ __ ] yeah i same
i'm [ __ ] yeah literally my people
from the caucus mountains like they get
more cautious irish people were not
considered white for a while yeah
they're white as [ __ ] irish
people are not considered white polish
people were not considered white greek
people are not considered white italians
were not considered white italians still
are poc so that's a little different
yeah no hey come on yeah protect the
group exactly this is marginalized
but jewish people similar
and
and it is constantly expanded hispanic
people are now considered white as well
and they were not originally as a matter
of fact
all benny franks
once famously wrote benjamin franklin
once famously wrote you'll fly on that
head really okay it's gone sorry is it
there's a lot of flies everywhere andrew
franklin once famously wrote germans
were not considered white wow that's a
hot take because the germans were
swarthy they were too swarthy to be
considered white like the the
anglo-saxon protestant that's a hot tank
yeah or the anglo-saxon yeah so um
it's a totally fabricated made-up
question yeah i think you make a great
uh very compelling point is like this
idea because there people always try to
trivialize this idea of like why can't i
be proud of being white you can be proud
of being black you could be proud of
being jewish you could be proud of being
turkish why can't i be proud of being
white
well the reason is because what the [ __ ]
is whiteness
like what what are you what what are
actually where are you from yeah we're
and and that is the main difference
between white culture and black culture
when people say white culture does not
exist it's more it's more about being
proud of not being them then being proud
of who you are exactly and the other
part of this and this is like important
for a lot of people to recognize is that
um
there is no there's no white culture
there is english culture there's irish
culture
there is a french culture
and americans know that black people on
the other hand specifically african
descendants of slaves do not know that
because of chattel slavery that's the
reason why there is such a thing as
black culture because it's a collective
culture built within oppression between
a collective culture built on top of the
collective struggle that black people
faced they had to build their own
identity they had to build their own
culture
because they were robbed from their
homes
raped genocided colonized and that's why
they can't trace their ancestral lineage
back to like whatever country that they
come from and that's why there is a
black culture that was built in that
intergenerational trauma and struggle
that's a great point i mean bla
african-american is a very distinct
cultural identity like because you said
their past was erased in a lot of cases
like you think what you think
jefferson is a traditional black last
name like no it's not a traditional
african last name
it's the last name of a [ __ ] slave
owner like that's where that comes from
washington and so what about someone who
you know says well i'm a white american
and that's my culture why can't i be
proud and white well it's like you can
be proud of like i guess being english
or something sure i love being english
that doesn't sound racist i love being
english i love being german whatever you
say if i love being white that makes it
that sounds racist because it's more i'm
proud that i'm not you yeah because it
doesn't mean anything and it's a it's a
totally it that like white pride and
white power is also
um co-opted by the black power movement
like whenever whenever marginalized
people
want to um fight back against their
oppression and their oppressors
there's a lot of racist white people or
racist oppressors colonizers that are
like well if they're doing that i'm
gonna build a [ __ ] counter movement
around that mm-hmm
you have all lives matter to the black
lives matter i mean all lives matter
yeah that's why you have a police lives
matter to the black lives matter that's
why you have which [ __ ] police is not
even a race which is ridiculous blue
lives matter they weren't even [ __ ]
trying on that one they were just like
yeah [ __ ] black people that's what they
should have just called that um
and and same with like you know when you
have a pro-choice movement you have a
pro-life movement like conservatives
don't give a [ __ ] about life give me a
break they just they just want you to
forcibly carry a pregnancy to term
that's it that's what the honest name of
that movement is but they use you know
some clever marketing tactics to make
their smell they're good marketers man
they they
they very cleverly and very expertly or
at least some of the think tanks churn
out this kind of they're good man
and co-opted uh this is
oppressed uh people that was a great
breakdown i really appreciated that
i think it it it
informs why what he's saying is such a
[ __ ] psychotic take on primetime
television in america but notice how
hard it is to [ __ ] break that [ __ ]
down because right it's so much easier
to go along with the pre-existing bias
that's built in that like society has
taught you it's so much harder to be
proud of being white and you go well i
guess that makes sense exactly and
that's the that's the beauty of that
kind of propaganda that kind of like
it's so easy to get hooked in with that
i was like yeah i'm white and i'm proud
exactly
they brag about it all the time but if
you dare to say it's happening they will
scream at you with maximum hysteria and
here you have joe biden confirming his
motive on tape with a smile on his face
an unrelenting strength what happened
did it cut they cut out the i guess they
cut it out
and it's not even
it's not oh no it's restarted it just
restarted so the funny thing is like
it's a video it's footage from 2015 when
joe biden is talking about wasn't the
president yeah uh which is hilarious
like he went back in time to like clip
chimp him like all the time he's making
a story out of some old ass [ __ ] yeah
because he wants to tie it back to like
joe biden wants haitian migrants to come
into the country and ooh spooky you know
here's the clip replace the white folk
here wait here's a washington post
uh can you leave me alone please thank
you peace and love
so here is
here's the clip that he's made this
whole yeah an unrelenting stream of
immigration
non-stop
non-stop
folks like me who were
caucasian of european descent
for the first time in 2017 will be an
absolute minority in the united states
of america
absolute minority
fewer than 50 percent of the people in
america from then and on
will be
white european stock that's not a bad
thing that's that's the source of our
strength
got in yeah an unrelenting stream of
immigration but why well joe biden just
said it to change the racial mix of the
country that he didn't say that
he said diversity is our strength that's
precisely what he said and it does not
matter the anecdote is in reference to
lee's estimation um
but it doesn't matter because he already
it's very compelling he's already
talking to an audience of people who are
like yeah you're right it is it's very
compelling yeah if you're susceptible or
even a little susceptible and you're
like oh my god tuck the dick is right
exactly he's missing key contacts
they're talking about a conversation
with the singapore prime minister
anecdotes in reference to lee's
estimation china's interest in
unearthing a metaphorical black box
which unholds what the [ __ ] is this
talking about that there is in america
there is an overwhelming skepticism for
orthodoxy
from the time a child whether they're
naturalized or their native born
they think about it a child never gets
criticized in our education system for
challenging
orthodoxy
for challenging the status quo
i would argue it's unlike any other
large country in the world
so there's a second thing in that black
box an unrelenting stream of immigration
yeah nonsense he's saying diversity and
challenging orthodoxy are the two key
americans
who were
that's amazing how he took that out of
context he's talking historically yeah
which is undoubtedly true i know he but
he's a psycho and like the question you
got to always ask people is like oh my
god i gotta ask this question
and whenever someone you the listeners
if you have someone in your family like
this who's like yeah why it's actually
bad that white people are you know uh
they're they're going away it's and you
know real nazis will call it white
genocide which is laughable like imagine
being so privileged that you think like
people immigrating into this country is
like genocide
genocide's when people murder you yeah
for you know being a certain way but
um
ask them the question like why is that a
bad thing
just sit there and wait
they would say because they know they
vote democrat and we're they're gonna
they're gonna
that's not gonna
well that's what they'll say but it
doesn't matter but it's true latin
latinos are conservative uh not even
true texas massively latino uh massively
latino state and yet they still hate
them well um
it's it's a it's a bit of it's it's just
pure racism for the most part but
um it's it's purely it's motivated even
if they recognize it or or not recognize
it as mo it's definitely motivated a lot
by racial resentment like and and white
purity
um it's just super old school you want
to see white purity look at this inbred
[ __ ] who wants to look like that
that dude looks his face looks like corn
on the cob bro yeah he got jacked though
i think he's like doing steroids lately
oh did he oh yeah yeah yeah he doesn't
look so anyway
here's the face of white purity look at
these faces my god yeah
uh jelly donut and corn on the cob
here's fox news so basically uh tuck the
dick carlson is making literally the
same argument as the kkk grand wizard
david duke i think that our heritage in
this country is being lost i'm not
against the rights of any minorities but
i think this
i'm not against the rights of any
minorities but i want to strike down all
mexicans dead where they stand yeah i
want to kill them at the border they
want to they want to purge them it's
like well how are you going to do that
in a non-violent way i'm not against
their rights but i do want to go into
their house and kill their babies when
they sleep yeah
to being a third world nation we have a
moral obligation to admit the world's
poor they tell us even if it makes our
own country poorer and dirtier and more
divided
yeah like literally losing he's just
straight saying like immigrants
man shut the [ __ ] up i bet that
[ __ ] doesn't even have a bidet
bro wash your [ __ ] ass tucker carlson
you dumb [ __ ] talking about immigrants
being dirty like [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
oh so that's a whole another stinky it's
just like he's such a [ __ ]
he's such a garbage [ __ ]
hog of the week hug of the decade but
but this is interesting now this is
mainstream television the same talking
points as kkk grand wizards integrity of
our society
our children are going to be growing up
for strangers in their own land
of immigration i'm surrounded by
mexicans joe biden just said it to
change the racial mix of the country
that's the reason to reduce the
political power of people whose
ancestors lived here and dramatically
for a second that's the best part it's
like yo i didn't know you were a native
american you can't even go there yeah
you can't even go there the people whose
ancestors lived here like what the [ __ ]
we were born we were we were growing out
the earth we were i was i was born from
a seed back 10
million years ago silly but but hey
donald trump did the exact same thing
donald trump if you remember uh once
said you know aoc
ayanna presley and and ilhan omar and
rashida talib should go back to their
own countries it's the best and it's
like
yeah well except for well uh except for
iran omar isn't she born in america
ilhan omar yeah no she's a somali
refugee um but
but it doesn't matter because everyone
else with the acceptance of omar
has been in the united states for many
generations especially aoc who's been in
the united states for longer like her
family has been in the united states for
more generations than [ __ ] donald
trump's mm-hmm so what the [ __ ] are you
talking about dude like it's just it's
actually it's so blatant white period
yeah it's like awesome i'm white
such as
my ancestors the hate that aoc gets is
is to me always so ironic she is such a
salt of the earth such an amazing
american dream story bartending working
a working class american
rises up from the ranks to become a
starlet a a highly popular elected
official that's an acting change you
know that's a that's a good american
story and i don't know and it's just
it's amazing how they spin it right yeah
she's brown he's brown
here's more kkk talking points for you
guys to enjoy
twitter video is so bad
i [ __ ] up i accident let me refresh
i don't want to take away the rights i
just want to come in your house in the
middle of the night and murder your
family i think that our heritage in this
country is being immigration but why
well joe biden just said it to change
the racial mix of the country that's
this guy's not even white let's be
honest he's red
yeah
i mean he's like he's like a lacrosse uh
guy you know and i mean you can just
hey i i found like an old photo i was
hanging out with the channel 5 guys
yeah of course andrew yeah so they
showed me they found an old photo of
tucker carlson and he's got like his
pants are like
they're swagging oh he's flat oh yeah
his pants were like dick level
oh for real yeah he's got the [ __ ]
lachuga the [ __ ] hair you know he's
like a big he was wearing a polo tee
with the [ __ ]
popped collars like
man he's just like a straight [ __ ]
bro like and that's the thing like he
used to be on cnn like he was a bow tie
guy on cnn yeah you know what i mean
like no he's a [ __ ] media demon he
knows he knows what he's doing he's he's
really good at what he does
unfortunately what he does happens to be
i do actually think he's a white
supremacist whose ancestors lived here
and dramatically increased the
proportion of americans newly arrived
from the third world you have a rapidly
declining european american majority and
if we don't reverse this soon we will be
a minority in our own country we gotta
kill the mexican babies outnumbered and
out voted in our land and no matter what
you think about any issue you will be
powerless
to make your voice heard in government
this policy is called the great
replacement the replacement of legacy
americans with more obedient people
legacy americans
the [ __ ] isn't that like the beta beta
americans he's such a [ __ ] dude you
can't even say it like that's the
funniest thing i'm trying to replace the
legacy americas with the 2.0 bro he's
just like he's such a [ __ ] he's such a
cuck like he can't [ __ ] straight up
say it i mean he's just trying to dance
around the 14 words you know what i mean
like
he's so pathetic he's replacing legacy
americans uh legacy americans like shut
up [ __ ] we know what you're trying to
say
like
the [ __ ] is the legacy americans dude
well a legacy
yeah i mean yeah i mean a legacy
american is a native american
yeah
to be frank
so that's about it oh this was a great
take too uh as we wrap it up here um he
says that vaccine is for
low is
our ploy to identify high testosterone
men
you seen this
no
watch this the point of mandatory
vaccination is to identify the sincere
christians in the ranks the free
thinkers the men with high testosterone
wait paul literally
there's no scientific basis for this is
the funniest [ __ ] uh lower third
because there's literally
no scientific basis for anything he's
saying he's doing a bit where he's like
i don't know it's true i don't know it's
true i just feel it he's just like
talking directly out of his ass there's
literally no sense of humor in the
delivery though so yeah this is just a
legal disclaimer more than a bit pretty
much yeah i feel like fox news lawyers
would probably use that in court to be
like well we wrote it we [ __ ] wrote
it yeah kind of your fault for believing
us who would believe this
no reasonable person would believe this
yeah mandatory vaccination is to
identify the sincere christians in the
ranks the free thinkers the men with
high testosterone levels bro i'm sorry
but how do you say men with high
testosterone levels without even like
cracking a smile that to me is mental
the funny is the funniest part about
this is like listen i mean tucker does
he not know like a single person who's
served i don't understand like
dude the the first day of basic you get
hit with every vaccine they put you in a
[ __ ] line okay like cattle and they
[ __ ] jab you up with every vaccine
and there is mandatory vaccines in the
military just like there are george
washington had a [ __ ] mandatory
vaccine during the revolutionary war
exactly i mean it's just and it is a
very american thing to do uh georgia
america george washington was a damn
enough hated america nothing says alpha
like eating [ __ ] you know
3 000 calorie mres and then being afraid
of a [ __ ] you know
vaccine that like more than a billion
people have taken so far and are
perfectly fine like three billion
inoculations so far in the world but
like our our alphas our alpha dogs in
the american military uh they're you
know that's that's one step too far
backs or leave the the if you're in the
military and your anti-vagus is the
funny you're the stupidest person like
you are literally the dumbest person bro
they are testing like they're giving you
juice by the way giving you like anthrax
vaccines that are going to [ __ ] you up
like desert storm the face of alpha male
that's a high testosterone male right
there my friends yeah exactly bow tie to
me says alpha all the way i mean
i mean he's chinless as [ __ ] i'm sorry
it's like i mean he is the picture
representation of the version it's just
so funny whenever they're like they they
try to portray masculinity well hold on
you're gonna call this man chinless uh
sorry but get in line for the gun for
the hot show with a little spittle in
the in the corner
what i don't understand is like if you
like i'm not
i'm not the type of dude to be like oh
yeah depictions of masculinity are
incredibly important or whatever like i
don't give a [ __ ] you know people really
like get bent out of shape when i paint
my nails and stuff but like
if you look like this then maybe don't
try to say like well real alpha men look
a certain way i don't look that way but
i'm an alpha man too it's like well no
you're not i guess he's a hog i mean i
think his race is hog he looks like a
[ __ ] farm animal and anyone else who
does not love joe biden and make them
leave immediately it's a takeover of the
us military yeah that's how they're
doing it
this show has just obtained a powerpoint
that the army is using to justify the
mandatory power points to the troops
this is an actual slide from it on your
screen they found that you will notice
there the sympathetic portrayal of
satanism
how many children what the [ __ ] is this
they said this is a powerpoint from the
army the seven tenets of satanism what
the [ __ ] is this questions for the
friday how many children were
sacrificing satan for the vaccine what
the [ __ ]
uh i don't know what the [ __ ] this is
what are they saying like the military
satan is now uh one should strive to act
with compassion empathy towards all
creatures oh this is the seventh tenets
of spirit the satanist church is like a
meme do you have any intel on this
sacrifice to satan because the vaccine
the slide reads apparently sarcastically
then the first presentation proceeds to
list the soul he recognizes our satanism
which are taken straight from the temple
of satanism website
so here you have the united states army
doing pr for satanism uh-huh he already
admitted it was a presentation
uh
some secretary somewhere in the middle
of the funniest thing are we really is
this like coming down
don't get me started talk about the
military like i will get real spicy i'm
just gonna let you know like
we don't have enough time left yeah you
will you will lose your sponsors if that
happens but
my point is like
one last thing one last thing
i gotta pee on tuck this is it we're
gonna end on this this was my favorite
tucker moment
in a while i won't be i'm gonna watch
this you're gonna want to pee after you
you're gonna pee your pants okay let's
see he calls into dave ruben of course
the uh paragon of uh free thought one
day we'll talk about this too i i used
to work with him as you know at the um
dave rubin a man who's sincere as
sincere
when you have to cover some idiotic
thing that stelter said or cuomo
just these these clown people when you
have to cover it right or don le man as
you call them like what how do you think
they live with themselves at this point
when they just lie again and again and
we have the internet to expose them
20 years ago when you were on cnn
he's definitely been drinking bro
mommy is hitting the sauce
no shop
oh totally alcoholic fat face you know
alec baldwin's style
oh is that why like val kimmer has a
huge head do you think yeah dude alcohol
it gives you a fat crazy it just like
makes you just i don't know what it is
but like you're [ __ ] you got all
picked off it gets blown that's
interesting
yellow liver damage no no
that'd be tight
and we couldn't expose things we can
expose it now and they still do it
well it's i guess i would ask myself
like i mean i lie
if i'm really cornered or something i
lie
i really try not to
i try never to lie on tv i tr i just
don't you know i don't like lying i
certainly do it you know out of weakness
or whatever how can you say i'm just i'm
mind
[ __ ]
that he would come out and say i lie
when i'm backed in a corner well because
he knows nobody watches the rumor report
okay fair enough and also the ones who
do watch the reuben report they're
vegetables how can you say this your
tucker calls in the master of propaganda
he must be pissed drunk i just i don't
understand him to say bro i lie on my
show when i'm backed into a corner he's
what i'm telling you because he knows
like only vegetables watch the rubber
130 000 people watch this and by the way
reuben you know the master he doesn't
call him out like wait you [ __ ] just
said you lie on your show when you're
backed into a corner let's listen to
what it's what his follow-up is
but to systematically lie like that to
lie like they lie now that's a whole
different story i lied when i backed
into a store and backed into a corner
but to live like them
unforgivable
asking yourself like why am i doing this
so if if these people ask themselves why
am i doing this you say well because i
want to protect i dare you to ask them
did you just absolutely
okay who's running back into a corner
you're you're lying to defend jeff bezos
like you're treating what do you like to
defend bro
burdock very different billionaire tell
me who you lie you just said you lied
why do you lie some sort of moral leader
like are you kidding me
everybody loves jeff bezos i i like this
because like look first of all jeff
bezos was technically my boss you know
what i'm saying well i am a tweet i
guess that's true he's you're he's yeah
he's tagging him
yeah i mean he's also [ __ ] jacked i'm
not being paid to say this he is jack
though he's he's definitely doing trt
anyway um allegedly sorry trt though
like hormones testosterone replacement
therapy uh he might be doing hgh
actually because he's got fungus he's
got baby blood he's got that hydro what
do you call the baby blood uh chemical
what what can you know
what is it called adrenochrome
yeah adrenaline adrenochrome yeah yeah
uh he's he's definitely doing everything
i mean peter thiel literally has blood
boys so allegedly he get you know how
you there was that theory about how
there was like
random amazon items for five thousand
dollars that's where you get that
adrenal crisis i love those things this
is like so silly jeff bezos is out here
looking like a superman villain yeah i
mean he's [ __ ] jack yo i'll have what
he's on yeah he he's got that divorce
body you know for sure good for him yeah
bill gates not so much bill gates is out
here catching l's on [ __ ] judy
woodruff i love pbs newshour oh well
there's nothing new about epstein well
like he's dead you do that he's that
dare you use your power
to protect and guard the powerful free
speech even honest conversation well i
love this way
pause for a second when he says like how
dare you protect your uh you know speech
to
protect the powerful it's like bro you
literally do the 14 words every night
like who do you think is
like he
does he think that like the guatemalan
abuela is the [ __ ] most powerful
person in america's society like that's
walking over the border because that's
hanging on
the caravan is coming yeah it's like
yeah dude i know i mean when i think of
the centers of american power i think of
a [ __ ] honduran migrant that walked
here like that's literally who i think
of when i think of centers of american
power i'm just dying to know what he
just admit to lying to about and and you
know i mean everything i would assume
reuben being such a hard-hitting
journalist and conversationalist he's
going to ask him immediately on the
follow-up what do you lie about dave
rubin the weakest piece
some catholic school kid from kentucky
it's like a parody are you kidding he's
a child
oh they're still talking about the
covington kids
oh my god they love their old like like
that that shock you okay you ever seen
i gotta see reuben's follow up
have you ever seen conservatives like
that have like old school
merch is like i'm trying to find this
maybe someone can find it for me
um
oh don't do it dude
this is an electric swatter okay
[ __ ]
i got it oh
it did explode where'd it go
it's tough somewhere
okay this is probably on me okay you're
good you're good so
just a little cooked fly so what i was
gonna say is like there's this
conservative merch that i love it's like
i never forgave jane fonda because like
you know hanoi jane is like [ __ ]
it's 20 20. like you're still wearing a
shirt that like
the you
that you don't forgive jane fonda for
what like she's older than you like
you're you're that big over vietnam
still like
the [ __ ]
and they hold on to these grievances
forever like tucker carl's gonna talk
about that covington kid whoa they're
still upset about the
the civil war that's true they're
they'll never forget big l
generally
yeah we must keep up his statues oh that
was a fat l that was a big i haven't
gotten over it it was really [ __ ]
good i wish the
participation trophies dude [ __ ] wait
i'm dying for a reuben follow-up like
very substantial power that we have
to put pictures on the screen
to uh reuben follow-up is
upwards they should have never just
i mean that's why reuben forgot already
i mean reuben's just there
to his seasoning he's not doing [ __ ]
here's a little meme for you oh yeah
yeah that's what i'm doing that's the
juice i can't forgive jane fonda when
the jews forgive hitler hmm
yeah dude hannah or jane
what did jane fonda even do
she was uh she was a massive massive
anti-war uh activist uh back during the
video
of defending vietnam um psychos like i
thought we had
closed the book on vietnam yeah we
[ __ ] took a fat l there too it was
like that's like i'm you know viet cong
one american forces zero
taliban one
united states forces zero you know we
just keep taking l's with dudes and
flip-flops
right
using ak-47s
yeah you know we we don't have a good
hit uh
exactly uh storied past oh you well you
were saying that bill gates
wasn't ready for the dating world and
yeah
well well you know this is what baby
blood extract will do to you so
if he's trying i don't know why he
doesn't get jacked like that
because
he should doesn't want to do the work
just like me
but like it doesn't make you're rich
enough just like you don't you know
you're doing [ __ ] he wants to pay people
to do [ __ ] for him he with exercising
you have to put in the work yourself you
know he's horny of course he's [ __ ]
everything that came out yeah he's
trying to [ __ ] everybody i mean he was
like hanging out with jeffrey epstein so
yeah you know what i mean like i mean he
was he was did it came out during the
divorce that he was like flirting with
the secretary he was getting hands with
everybody melinda's pr team is
devastating
like i she is i mean the story itself
bro they put out like 13 articles about
how bill gates loves jeffrey epstein on
the daily beast alone i was like god
damn melinda you well you know throwing
this man you know
she was sheep because i'm telling you no
one
like a woman scorned right i mean she
had her finger on the button yeah i mean
she deserves it you know hit me up
melinda i'm i'm here for you
i i'll be your baby you're gonna would
you sugar daddy melinda sugar
should you sugar baby you'd be a sugar
baby yeah [ __ ] yeah dude whatever she's
not a bad looking older lady let's let's
pull it up she's a very like she she
looks like my do you think she's getting
strange dick
melinda yeah oh my god are you thinking
she's getting weird yeah strange dick
she got like two 24 year old models like
you know
if she's into it of course i don't you
know
bill you [ __ ] up i just i the fact of
the idea of bill gates like
like
you know
she could be insane she looks good
bill's definitely into some kinky stuff
too
come on come on let the just pour the
baby blood on my penis and we'll take it
from there
come on melinda just take the vial and
open it yeah no he's yeah melinda wasn't
into my kids bill gates gets off on like
[ __ ] you know
vaccinating african babies and stuff i
don't think he's in the melinda pull up
the video of us forcibly uh sterilizing
african babies hold up the cake and i'll
get my now my dick's hard
no he yeah he loves he loves destroying
the public school system of the united
states like that's what that's that's
the kind of [ __ ] that he's into that's
his kink well he's probably got a back
door to like everybody's laptop too he
can just pull up anyone's [ __ ]
probably
webcam
i don't think oh for sure no those
[ __ ] he's not a coder bro these
guys like dude he's got the back door
like you think like elon musk knows how
to [ __ ] he doesn't know anything he's
just live front man the whole point of
microsoft is literally just so bill
gates can jerk off looking through
anyone's webcam that's why the company
was built damn you okay you you
convinced me
all right guys
that's our first episode
it's a work in progress but we had i had
fun i had a lot of fun we we were
supposed to we went on for
16 minutes over what we were supposed to
do by the way you know why it's called
the leftovers because we're lefties and
nobody likes politics so it's like the
leftover content okay i got it i mean
i'm a little offended yeah it is offense
it's self-depre it's offended me as i
said it yeah i mean i i love politics i
i cover it for hours and hours and hours
every day so
i i love politics
and um
uh not it's not for everyone but what i
appreciate so much about you and why i'm
so happy i'm making the show with you
is because you made it popular you made
it cool and i love and respect so much
what you've done oh thank you and to be
able to sit and have a show with you is
a true uh
true i'm truly blessed oh hey hopefully
hopefully the fans feel the same way i
hope they like it yeah
were you all trying to get me vaccinated
yeah
i wonder i mean i'm sure you're
your audience is like i don't know i
don't know what you're uh i think we
should shed most of the uh of kova
truthers by now yeah probably i don't
think there's man they're all watching
joe rogan in the in the hospital
crt tv
we we [ __ ] on joe rogan and anti-vaxxers
enough at this point that
i don't think there's many left but if
they are i mean you know don't leave
keep watching for christ's sake don't
leave and [ __ ] get vaccinated okay or
you're gonna end up on the hermitcain
wars getting owned by a bunch of
libtards yeah and if that doesn't
motivate you i don't know what does
this is the leftovers
is that are we signing off god true ble
we're true american hero hell yeah look
at our success
and what's more american than that
that's right we salute and we we love
our troops right exactly we love our
troops we salute our troops we live for
liberty and justice for all we live by
american ideals
and god bless america folks god bless
america and god bless our troops mmm
thank you for your service i can't
salute for that long i don't know
i think it's the
last time
[Music]